[Music]
hello everyone so hopefully we're going
to get past Genesis 1 today that's the
theory so I finished my new book
yesterday yes that's that's taken about
three years of writing it's quite a long
time to write something so yeah I'm it's
done except for the mopping up you know
copy editing and that sort of thing so
hopefully it's as good as I can make it
I don't know that's any good but it's as
good as I can make it anyways alright so
this is the stories that I'm going to
tell you tonight I've been thinking
about well like the ones last week for
that matter for a very long period of
time but I think these even longer and
one of the things that I just do not
understand I cannot fathom this I cannot
understand how there can be so much
information in such tiny little stories
especially the story of Cain and Abel
that story just every time I read it it
just flattens me because it it's only
like a paragraph long there's just
nothing to it you know and I think about
it I think about it and I think about it
I think about it every time I think
about it another layer comes out from
underneath and then another layer comes
out from underneath it and I can't
figure that out like you know the
rational approach that I've been
describing to you is predicated on the
idea that these stories have somehow
encapsulated wisdom that we generated
interpersonally and behaviorally in that
an image over very vast stretches of
time and then condensed it into very
very dense articulated words that are
then further refined by the act of being
remembered and transmitted and
remembered and transmitted over vast
stretches of time and that's a pretty
good argument I'm willing to
I'm willing to go with it but it still
never ceases to amaze me how much
information such tiny little passages
can can contain so we'll take that apart
today and I think it's especially true
with the story of Cain and Abel because
it works on the individual level and it
works on the familial level and it works
on the political level and it works at
the level of warfare and it works at the
level of economics and it's that's a lot
for a little tiny one paragraph story to
cover man now you know you could object
well with these stories you never know
what you're reading into it and what's
in the story right that's part of let's
call it the postmodern dilemma and fair
enough and there's really no answer to
that any more than there is an answer to
how do you know your interpretation of
the world is well let's not say correct
but sufficient there's some answer to
that it's sufficient in if you can act
it out in the world and other people
don't object too much and you don't die
and nature doesn't take a bite out of
you any more often than necessary you
know those are the constraints within
which we live so it you have some way of
determining whether your interpretation
is at least functionally successful and
that's and that's not trivial and I
guess you can say the same thing to the
interpretations that might be laid out
on these stories and at the moment
that's probably good enough hopefully
you find the interpretations
functionally significant at multiple
levels and I also think the chance of
managing that by chance is very very
small you know to be able to pull off an
interpretation of the story that works
at multiple levels simultaneously you
think with each level that it applies
the chances that you've stumbled across
something by chance have to be
decreasing right there's a technical
term for that in psychology it's called
something like multi method multi trait
method of determining whether or not
something is accurate and the idea is
the more ways that you can measure it
and get the same result the more
confident you can be that you're not
just deluding yourself with your a
priori hypothesis you know that there's
actually something
out there so I guess that's another part
of this method is that and it's also a
method that I use in my in my speaking I
think I don't try to tell people
anything that isn't personally relevant
you know because you should know why you
are being taught something right you
should know what the fact is good for
and it should be good for you personally
at least in some sense and then if you
act it out in the world it should be
good for your family and maybe should
have some significance for the broader
community and I think that's what
meaning means and I don't really see the
utility in being taught things that
aren't meaningful facts that aren't
meaningful because there's an infinite
number of fact and there's no way you're
going to remember all of them they have
to be they have to have the aspect of
tools essentially something like that
because we are tool using creatures well
these these stories have that aspect is
as far as I can tell there's nothing
there's no doubt about that
so here's the stories in Genesis two
very famous stories obviously virtually
everybody who's even vaguely versed in
Western roughly speaking Western Western
culture knows these stories and that's
something that's interesting too that
stories can be so foundational that
everybody shares them I mean you can say
the same thing about a fairly large
handful of fairy tales as well or you
could at least until recently but the
fact that stories are foundational I
think also means that they have to be
given out kind of well even if you don't
give them any respect you have to at
least treat them as remarkable
curiosities so why those stories and why
did they stick around and why does
everybody know them and it's not
self-evident by any stretch of the
imagination and you can use explanations
can use the Freudian explanation Freud
sort of thought that the judeo-christian
was predicated on the idea that the
figure of the Father the familial father
was expanded up into cosmic dimensions
so that mankind existed in the same
relationship to the cosmic father let's
say that an infant or a small child
existed in relationship to his or her
own father and that's a reasonable
critique I would say to some degree but
it does
and this was purposeful it does imply
more than implied for its case that
people who adopt religious belief that
has a personified figure as at its apex
are essentially acting out the role of
dependent children and you know I
thought about that critique for a long
time and believe me that's been a
powerful critique one of the best books
I've ever read called the denial of
death by Ernest Becker I think took that
line of argumentation it developed it as
well as any any book I've ever seen
argue it Necker tried to bring closure
to Freudian psychoanalysis on religion
he did a pretty wicked job of it like I
think the book is seriously flawed and
wrong but it's really a great book like
some books are well some books are wrong
in really good ways right they make a
powerful powerful argument they really
take it to its extreme
I think Becker missed the point and he
missed it in the same way that Freud
missed Jung's point and Becker who wrote
this book on the psychology the
psychoanalysis of religion never
referred to Jung except very briefly in
the introduction and I think that was a
major mistake but Becker took the
argument that the hypothesis of God is
nothing but an attempt by human beings
to recreate quasi infantile state of
dependency and to be able to rely on an
all-knowing father and to thereby
recover the comfort perhaps that we
experienced when we were young and had a
hypothetically all-knowing father for
those of us who are lucky to have
someone who rig vaguely resembled that
but the more I thought about that the
more that struck me is quite implausible
across time Charles Taylor I think it
was Charles Taylor wrote an interesting
book called the I think it was called
the origins of the modern self he's a
McGill philosopher and I wouldn't
necessarily call him a friend of classic
religion but it doesn't matter he made a
very interesting point about
Christianity in particular he said if
you're going to invent a religion that
offered you nothing but
infantile comfort why in the world would
you bother with conceptualizing hell
that just seems like an unnecessary
detail to add to the whole story right
if it's it's all about comfort why would
you hypothesize that the consequence of
of a serious error was eternal torment
that doesn't really sound very isn't the
sort of thing that that is likely to
make you feel comfortable James Joyce
when he wrote about that said he had
terrible nightmares when he was a child
because of the Hellfire sermons that
Jesuits used to spout spew forth let's
say and he wrote down what he remembered
of them and they were pretty
hair-raising I think in James Joyce's
book I think it was portrait of the
artist of a young man man he talked
about the Jesuits telling them and
telling him that hell was a like a
prison with walls that were seven miles
thick that was always in darkness and
consumed by fire and that the people who
were trapped there were continually
burnt by this dark fire that gave new
light which also simultaneously
rejuvenated their flesh so that it could
be burnt off eternally in case you were
wondering how it was going to be burnt
off eternally that's apparently the
process it's not easy for me to see that
as an infantile wish-fulfillment
I'm afraid you know you could well you
could be a cynic about it and Elaine
Tasos who wrote a book on the devil was
cynical about it in this manner she
thought that the Christians so to speak
invented hell as a place to put their
enemies and you know yeah fair enough
but no that's not accurate
really well although it's convenient to
have a place to put your enemies Charles
Taylor did point out for example that
the modern terror of loss of self let's
say the existential loss of self and
loss of meaning was perhaps roughly
paralleled by the medieval terror of
Hell
you know in terms of the existential
intensity and so it wasn't hell wasn't
merely a place where those people that
you didn't care for would end up it was
the place where you were going to go if
you didn't walk the line properly and so
I don't think Freud's Freud's critique
really holds water in the final analysis
and then Marx's critique of course was
that religion was the opiate of the
masses and he made an
argument that was similar to Freud's
although somewhat earlier and made the
based upon the presupposition that
religious beliefs were stories told to
the gullible masses in order to keep
them pacified and happy well their
corporate overlords for lack of a better
purpose continue to exploit them and and
and weaken them and you know I find that
I find the critique of human
institutions as driven entirely by power
very let's say questionable to to say
the least and of course every human
institution is corrupted by corrupted is
corrupt by for one reason or another and
it's also corrupt specifically by such
things as deception and arrogance and
the demand for unearned power and the
same thing of course can be applied to
religious systems but that doesn't mean
that they are in some special way
characteristic of those faults and maybe
you think they are and you know maybe
you can make a case for but it's not
prime FS I think that's how you say that
evident that that is that also is a
particularly useful criticism I don't
buy it
I think there's I think that's far too
cynical I think that the people who
wrote these stories first of all what
are you going to do you can oh really
you're going to run a bloody conspiracy
for three thousand years successfully
it's like good luck with that can't run
a conspiracy for fifteen minutes without
somebody ratting you out you know it's
it's impossible so whatever is that the
basis of the construction not only of
these stories but of the dogmatic
structures that emerged from them I
think that it's a terrible mistake to
reduce them to unit dimensional
explanations in fact I generally think
that reducing any complex human behavior
to uni dimensional explanation is often
the sign of a seriously limited thinker
you know I say that with some caution
because Freud did do that with religion
at least to some degree and Freud was a
serious thinker and Marx I suppose was a
serious thinker - even though well
yeah is he someone you just if you have
any sense marks just leaves you
speechless so so anyway so that's all to
say that I don't think there's any
simple explanation for how these stories
have the power that they have I really
don't I don't think you can reduce it to
political conspiracy that's for sure I
don't think you could reduce it to
psychological infantilism I think you
can make a case like I have that they
are repositories of the collective
wisdom of the human race I had an
interesting letter this week from
someone I get a lot of interesting
letters I think I'm going to make an
archive out of them and put them on the
web at some point with people's
permission obviously and he said that
he'd been following my lectures and
noted that I had been making what you
might describe as a quasi biological or
evolutionary case for for the emergence
of the information that the stories
contained and he said well how do you
know that someone from a different
religious tradition or speaking of a
different religious tradition couldn't
do exactly the same thing and I thought
well first of all to some degree they
could because there is overlap like I've
talked to you a little bit about Taoist
for example in the Taoist view of being
as you know the eternal balance between
chaos and order one thing I didn't tell
you I don't think about that I don't
know if you know this but there's a
neuropsychologist named L Conan Goldberg
who is a student of Alexander Luria and
Luria was I think the greatest
neuropsychologist of the 20th century he
was a Russian and he was one of the
first people to really determine in
large part the function of the frontal
cortex which was quite a mystery for a
very long period of time and Goldberg
you know you know how we have two
hemispheres right they have a left
hemisphere and the right hemisphere and
people often think of the left for
right-handed people right-handed males
more particularly because women are more
neurologically diffuse it's one of the
things that makes them more robust to
head injury for example and maybe men
are less diffuse and somewhat more
specialized which makes them a bit more
specialized but a little more subject to
damage anyways we have to him
is left in the right and no one exactly
knows why and we know that the house
quasi-independent consciousness is
because if you divide the corpus
callosum that that unites them which was
done to in cases of intractable epilepsy
for example that each hemisphere is
capable of developing its own
consciousness to some degree the right
generally nonverbal and the left verbal
and so there has been this idea that the
left is a verbal Hemisphere and the
right is a nonverbal hemisphere but that
can't be right because of course animals
don't talk and they have a bifurcated
hemisphere so if it's right it's not
causally right now goldberg hypothesized
instead that the hemispheres were were
specialized for routinization and non
routinization or for novelty and
familiarity or for chaos and order and
so that's pretty damn cool when i ran
across that i also thought about that as
a as a signal of what would you call it
multi method multi trait construct
validation because i'd never thought of
the hemispheres as operating that way
and goldberg came up with this in a
historical pathway that was entirely
independent from any mythologically
inspired thinking completely independent
fact it was motivated more by
materialist russian neuro psychology
which was materialist for political
reasons and also for scientific reasons
but the idea is that we have one
hemisphere that reacts very rapidly to
things we don't know and it's more
imaginative and diffuse in it and it's
associated more with negative emotion
because negative emotion is what you
should feel immediately when you
encounter something you don't understand
because it's a form of thinking right
negative emotion it's like I'm somewhere
where things aren't with what they
should be right hemisphere does that
generates images very rapidly to help
you figure out what might be there and
then the left hemisphere takes that and
develops it into something that's more
articulated and and algorithmic and
fully understood and so then there's
this dynamic balance between the right
and the left hemisphere where the left
tries to impose order on the world
that's Ramachandran who's a neurologist
in in california very famous neuro neuro
neurologist who also developed a theory
like goldberg who said that the left
hemisphere
or imposes routinized order on the world
and the right hemisphere generates
novelty and and and reacts the novelty
and generates novel hypotheses and he
thought and there is some good evidence
for this that's what's happening during
the dream is that information is moved
from the right hemisphere to the left
hemisphere in small doses basically so
that the novel revelations of the right
hemisphere don't demolish the
algorithmic structures that the left
hemisphere has so carefully put together
so and I like that theory too because it
also does help justify the hypothesis
that I'd be laying out for you which is
that you know there's part of us that
extends ourselves out into the world in
tries to understand what we don't know
and that that part extends itself out
with behavior and also with emotion and
also with image and then maybe with
poetry and then maybe with storytelling
and then as that develops then we
develop more and more articulated
representations of that emergent
knowledge and so you can map that quite
nicely onto the neurologists and the
neuropsychologist presumption about what
constitutes the reason for the
hemispheric differentiation but the
other thing that's so cool about the
hemispheric differentiation argument as
far as I'm concerned and this is really
this is worth thinking about man because
it's a real it's a real is a word that
Ned Ned Flanders uses for that noggin
scratcher I think it's something like
that anyways you know we do make the
assumption that what it is that we are
biologically adapted to is reality right
it's actually an axiomatic definition if
you're a Darwinian because nature is
what selects by definition that's what
nature is its what selects and if the
nature that selects has forced upon you
a dual hemispheric structure because
half of you has to deal with the chaos
and have to have a view has to deal with
order then you can make a pretty damn
strong inferential case that the world
is made out of chaos and order and
that's really something to that's really
something to think about man you know so
you can think about that for a while if
you want so
anyways for whatever reason there is a
lot to packed into these stories and so
let's investigate a couple more of them
we'll start with this story but of Adam
and Eve now you may remember that the
Bible is a series of books Bible
actually means something akin to library
and these books were written by all
sorts of different people and groups of
people and groups of editors and groups
of people who edited over and over
across very very large periods of time
so they're altered by no one and many at
the same time if there was a tradition
for a long time that the earliest books
were written by Moses but that that's
probably not technically correct even
though it might be dramatically correct
let's say or correct in the way that a
fairy tale is correct and I'm not trying
to put down fairy tales by saying that
but there's a number of authors and the
way the authors have been identified
tentatively is by certain stylistic
commonalities across the different
stories different uses of words like the
words for God different poetic styles
different topics and so forth and people
have been working for probably 200 years
roughly that to try to sort out who
wrote what and how that was all cobbled
together but it doesn't really matter
for our purposes what matters is that
it's an aggregation of collected
narrative traditions and maybe you could
say it's an aggregation of collective
narrative wisdom we don't have to go
that far but we can at least say it's
aggregated narrative traditions and that
there was some reason that those
traditions and not others were kept and
that there was some reasons complex
though they may have been why they were
sequenced in the order that they were
sequenced because one of the things
that's really remarkable about the Bible
as an as a document is that it actually
has a plot and that's really something I
mean it's it's sprawling and it goes
many places but the fact that
something's being cobbled together over
several thousand years maybe four
thousand years maybe longer than that if
you include the oral traditions that
preceded it and God knows how old those
are but that collective imagination part
of the human collective imagination has
cobbled together a library with a plot
and like I see the Bible as an attempt a
collective attempt by him
you solve the deepest problems that we
have and I think those problems are the
problems of primarily that the problem
of self-consciousness the fact that not
only do we are immortal and that we die
but that we know it and that's the
unique that's the unique predicament of
human beings and it makes all the
difference and I think that's laid out
in Adam and Eve in the story of Adam and
Eve I think the reason that that makes
us unique and is laid out in that story
and interestingly and I really realized
this only after I was doing last three
lectures so the Bible presents a
cataclysm of okay a Cataclysm at the
beginning of the top of time which is
the emergence of self-consciousness and
human beings which puts a risk into the
structure of being that's the right way
to think about it and that's really
given cosmic significance now you can
dispense with out and say well nothing
that happens to human beings that have
caused me significance because we're
these short-lived you know mold like
entities that are like cancers on this
tiny little planet that's rotating out
in the middle of nowhere on the edge of
some unknown galaxy in the middle of
infinite space and nothing that happens
to us matters and it's fine you like you
can walk down that road if you want I
wouldn't recommend it I mean and that's
part of the reason I think that for all
intents and purposes it's untrue you
know it isn't there it isn't a road you
can walk down and live well in fact I
think if you really walk down that road
and you really take it seriously you end
up not living at all
so it's certainly very reminiscent I
mean I've talked to lots of people who
are suicidal and seriously suicidal and
you know the kind of conclusions that
they draw both the utility of life prior
to wishing for its cessation are very
much like the kind of conclusions that
you draw if you walk down that
particular line of reasoning long enough
if you're interested in that you could
read Tolstoy his confessions Leo Tolstoy
his confession it's a very short book
it's a it's a killer man it's it's a
powerful book very very short and
Tolstoy describes his obsession with
suicide when he was at the height of his
fame most well-known author in the world
you know huge family international fame
wealth beyond anyone's imagining at that
time influential admired
everything that you could possibly
imagine that everyone could have and for
years he was afraid to go out into his
barn with a rope or a gun because he
thought he'd either hang himself or
shoot himself and he did get out of that
he and he describes why that happened
and where he went when that happened so
if you're interested in that that's a
very good book but so the biblical
stories and starting with Adam and Eve
they present a different story they
present the emergence of
self-consciousness in human beings as
cosmically cataclysmic event and you
could say well what do we have to do
with the cosmos and the answer to that
is it depends on what you think
consciousness has to do with the cosmos
and perhaps that's nothing and perhaps
it's everything I'm going to go with
everything because that's how it looks
to me now of course anyone who wishes to
is welcome to disagree but if you
believe that consciousness is a force of
cosmic significance which Britt which
which being itself is dependent on in
any real sense at least in any
experience will sense that it's that
it's not unreasonable to assume that
radical restructurings of consciousness
can worthily be granted some kind of
cosmic or metaphysical significance and
even if it's not true from outside the
human perspective whatever that might be
it's bloody well true from within the
human perspective that's for sure and so
that's the that's the initial event in
some sense after the creation is the
cataclysmic fall and then the entire
rest of the Bible is an attempt to
figure out what the hell to do about
that and everything in it is is and so
you could say for example in the
earliest in the Old Testament stories
what seems to happen is that the State
of Israel is is founded and it rises and
falls and rises and falls and so there's
this experimentation for centuries
millennia even with the idea that the
way that you protect yourself against
the tragic consequences of self
consciousness is by organizing yourself
into a state but then what happens is
the state itself begins to reveal its
pathologies and as those pathologies
mount the state becomes an unstable and
collapses and then it rises back up and
becomes unstable and collapses and then
it rises back up after it does this a
number of
this is primarily from Northrup prize
interpretations people start wondering
if there's not something wrong with the
idea that the state itself is this is
the is the pathway is the place of
redemption that there's something wrong
with that idea and so then I think on on
the heels of that comes the Christian
revolution with its hypothesis that it's
not the state that's that's the place of
salvation it's the individual psyche and
then there's there's a there's a an
ethic that goes along with that too
which is quite interesting so the ethic
of redemption after the state experiment
fails let's say is that it's it's the
it's within the individual that
redemption can be manifested let's say
and even in so far as the state is
concerned because the state's proper
functioning is dependent on the proper
functioning of the individual rather
than the reverse most fundamentally and
that the proper mode of individual being
that's redemptive is truth and truth is
the antidote to the suffering that's it
emerges with the fall of man in the
story of Adam and Eve and then that
relates back to the chapters that we've
already talked about because there's
this insistence in Genesis 1 that it's
the word in the form of truth that
generates order out of chaos but even
more importantly and this is something
like I said I most clearly realize just
doing these lectures for the last three
weeks is God continues to say as he
speaks order into being with truth that
the being he speaks into being is good
and so there's this insistence that the
being that spoke into being through
truth is good and so there's a hint
there so interesting is a hint there
right at the beginning of the story that
the the state of being that Adam and Eve
inhabited before they fell before they
became self consciousness conscious
insofar as they were made in the image
of God and acting out the truth that
that being itself was properly balanced
and it takes the entire Bible to
rediscover that which is a which is a
journey back to the beginning right and
that's a classic see
it's a classic mythological theme that
the wise person is the person who finds
what they lost in childhood and regains
it right so that's a I think that's a
Jewish idea that Zadok if I remember
correctly who is a messiah figure is the
person who finds what he lost in
childhood and regains it his idea of
this return to the beginning except that
the return is you don't fall backwards
into childhood and unconsciousness you
returned voluntarily to the state of
childhood
well awake and then determined to
participate through truth in the
manifestation of proper being now you
know I'm a psychologist and I've taught
personality theory for a very long time
and I know personality theory is that
profound personality theories pretty
well and I'm reasonably well versed in
philosophy although not as well-versed
as I should be but I can tell you in all
the things I've ever read or encountered
or thought about I have never once found
an idea that matches that in terms of
profundity but not only profundity also
in believability because the other thing
I see is a clinician and I think this is
very characteristic of clinical
experience and also very much described
explicitly by the great clinicians is
that what cures in therapy is truth
that's the curative now there's exposure
to the things you're afraid of and
avoiding as well but I would say that's
a form of enacted truth because if you
know there's something you should do by
your own set of rules and you're
avoiding it then you're enacting a lot
you know you're not telling one but
you're acting one out it's the same damn
thing so if I can get you to face what
it is that you're confronting that you
know you shouldn't be avoiding then
what's happening is that we're both
partaking in the process of attempting
you to act out your deepest truth and
what happens is that that improves
people's lives and it improves them
radically and the evidence the clinical
evidence to that is overwhelming we know
that if you expose people to the things
they're afraid of but that they're
avoiding they get better and you have to
do it carefully and cautiously and with
their own participation and all of that
but of all the things that clinicians
have established that's credible that's
number one and that's nested inside this
deeper realization that the clinical
experience is redemptive let's say
because it's designed to address
insofar as the people who are engaged in
the process are both telling each other
the truth and then you think well
obviously because if if you have some
problems and you come to talk to me
about them well first of all just by
coming to talk to me about them you've
admitted that they exist man that's a
pretty good start and second well if you
tell me about them then we know what
they are and then if we know what they
are we can maybe start to lay out some
solutions and then you can go act out
the solutions and see if they work but
if you don't admit they're there and you
won't tell me what they are and I don't
and I'm like posturing and acting
egotistically and taking the upper hand
and all of that in our discussions well
how the hell is that going to work you
know it might be comfortable moment to
moment while we stay encapsulated in our
delusion but it's not going to work so a
lot of that seems to think it through it
seems pretty self-evident and you know
Freud thought that repression was at the
heart of much mental suffering the
difference between repression and
deception is a matter of degree and
that's all its technical it's a
technical differentiation and Alfred
Adler who was one of Freud's greatest
associates would say and much
underappreciated I would say he thought
that people got into problems because
they started to act out a life lie
that's what he called it a life lie
that's worth looking up because I blur
although not as charismatic as Freud was
very practical and and and really
foreshadowed a lot of later developments
in cybernetics theory and of course Jung
believed that you could bypass
psychotherapy entirely by merely making
a proper moral effort in your own life
and Carl Rogers believed that it was
honest communication mediated through
dialogue that had redemptive
consequences and the behaviors believe
that you do a careful micro analysis of
the problems that are laid before you
and help introduce people to what
they're avoiding it's like all of those
things to me are just secular variations
of the notion that truth will set you
free essentially so so you know it's a
pretty powerful story and a it's not
that easy to dispense with and B the
other thing is you dispense with it at
your peril because what I have seen as
well is that the people that I've seen
who've been really hurt
have been hurt mostly by deceit and
that's all so we're thinking about that
you know you get walloped by life
there's no doubt about that absolutely
no doubt about that but I thought for a
long time that maybe maybe maybe people
can hang handle earthquakes and cancer
and even Gasparini but they can't handle
betrayal and they can't handle deception
they can't handle having the rug pulled
out from underneath and by people that
they love and trust that just does them
in you know it it makes the meal but it
does where it hurts that you know psycho
physiologically it damages them but more
than that it makes them cynical and
bitter and vicious and resentful and
then they also start to act all that out
in the world and that makes it worse so
so you know the story starts God uses
the spoken truth to create being that is
good and then the Cataclysm occurs and
then human beings spend until millenia
trying to sort out exactly what to do
about the fact that they've become self
conscious and you know by the way we
have right we are in fact self conscious
no other animal has that distinction
now you'll read that chimpanzees can for
example if you put lipstick on a
chimpanzee it's kind of a strange thing
to do yeah well I won't pursue that any
further but
but the chimp a chimpanzee will wipe off
the lipstick if you show it a mirror and
dolphins seem to be able to recognize
themselves in mirrors and there is so
there is the glimmerings of self
conscious recognition in other animals
but to put that in the same conceptual
category as human self-consciousness is
into my way of thinking it's it's well
it's uninformed to say the least but I
also think that it's motivated it's
motivated by a kind of anti humanistic
underlying and underlying motivation
because our self-consciousness is so
incredibly developed compared to that
that they're hardly in the same
conceptual universes it's like comparing
the the alarm cries of vervet monkeys
when they see a predator to the language
of human beings it's like yeah yeah
there's some similarities man there are
utter insanity nning but they're not
language and the self-consciousness of
animals is proto self-consciousness and
it's only they're a very small number of
animals and it's it's nothing like ours
they're not aware of the future like we
are they're not aware of their
boundaries in space and time and that's
the critical thing and most particularly
time human beings discovered time and
when we discovered time we discovered
the end of each of our being and that
made all the difference
and that's what the story of Adam and
Eve is about so Genesis one is derived
from the priestly source where God is
known as Elohim or L shall die and
there's God in the singular and there's
God's in the plural and I suppose that's
because it seems that if you analyze the
history of the development of
monotheistic ideas that monotheism
emerges out of a plurality of gods and
as I mentioned I think it's because the
gods represent fundamental forces at
minimum and those fundamental forces
have to be hierarchically organized for
with some with something absolute at the
top because otherwise they do nothing
but war like you have to organize your
values hierarchically or you stay
confused and that's true if you're an
individual and it's true of your estate
if you don't know what the next thing
you should do is then there's 50 things
you should do
and then how are you going to do any of
them you can't you have to prioritize
something has to be above something else
has to be arranged in a hierarchy for it
not to be chaotic and so there's some
principle at the top of the hierarchy
and maybe the organization of the gods
over time that's the battle of gods that
machiya le ADA talked about and if
you're interested in that you could read
a history of religious ideas which I
would really recommend it's a
three-volume book it's actually quite as
straightforward read as far as these
things go and elliot it does a very nice
job of describing how and even why
polytheism tends towards monotheism even
in polytheistic cultures there's a
strong tendency for the gods to organize
themselves in the hierarchy with one God
at the top in a monotheistic culture in
some in some sense all the other gods
just disappear across time and there's
nothing left at the top God but even in
a polytheistic society there's a
hierarchy of power among the gods the
first story is newer than the second one
so the story I'm going to tell you today
is actually older than the one I already
told you even though their order was
flipped by the redactor who's the
hypothetical person or persons who
edited these stories together we don't
know exactly why he or the committee or
what I suspect it was a single person
but who knows we don't know why the
stories were edited together in the
order that they were added together but
we could infer I mean they were edited
together in that order because the
editor thought they made sense that way
because that's what an editor does right
an editor tends to take diverse ideas
and then to organize them in some manner
that makes sense and part of the manner
that makes sense is that you can tell
them to people and the people stay
interested and you can tell them to
people and people remember them that's
that's one of the ways you can tell if
you've got an argument right because
it's communicable and understandable and
memorable and so he this person was
let's say motivated by intuition to
organize the stories in this particular
manner so the second the yahwist strand
contains the stories the classic stories
in the Pentateuch that's five books
Genesis Exodus Leviticus numbers and
Deuteronomy which we'll try to get
through perhaps in these twelve lectures
we'll see we'll see how that goes it's
strongly on through
perfect so the God in the August account
is for all intents and purposes a sort
of meta person and I dealt with that a
little bit last week because people tend
to you know think of that as
unsophisticated but when you think that
the mind that the the ground of
consciousness is the most complex thing
that we know of then it's not so
unsophisticated to assume that the most
complex thing that there might be is
like that or it's at least it's as good
as we can do with our imaginations and
so I don't think it's so it's so it's so
unsophisticated it's also the case and
this is practically speaking is that it
is not at all unreasonable to think of
God the Father as the spirit that arises
from the crowd that exists into the
future right and that's we talked about
that in relationship to the idea of
sacrifice at least a little bit more or
we're going to you make sacrifices in
the present so that the future is happy
with you the question is what is that
future that would be happy with you and
the answer to that is it's the spirit of
humanity that's that's who you're
negotiating with because you make the
assumption that if you forego impulsive
pleasure and get your medical degree
that when you're done in 10 years and
you're a physician humanity as such will
honor your sacrifice and commitment and
open the doors to you right so you're
treating the future as if it's a single
being and you're also treating it as if
it's a something like a compassionate
judge you're acting that out and maybe
we had to imagine God in that form
before we could understand once we
started to understand that there was a
future perhaps we had to imagine God in
that form in order to concretize
something that we could bargain with so
that we could figure out how to use
sacrifice to figure out how to guide
ourselves into the future because that
sacrifice is a contract with the future
but it's not a contract with any
particular person it's it's a contract
with the spirit of humanity as such it's
something like that and so when you
think about it that way that should make
you faint with amazement because that is
such a bloody amazing idea to come up
with that idea that you can bargain with
the future that is some idea man that's
that's like the major idea of human of
humankind
we suffer what do we do about it we
figure out how to bargain with the
future and we minimize suffering in that
manner it's like no other animal does
that either you know like the Lions they
just eat everything I think a wolf can
eat 40 pounds of meat in a single
sitting right it's like there's a meat
eat it
it's light not like save some mammoths
for tomorrow that's a that's that's not
a wolf thing man that's a human thing
and that might mean you have to be
hungry today
or maybe you're a farmer you know
several thousand years ago six thousand
years ago or so what agriculture first
got going and you're starving to death
waiting for the spring planting and you
think we bill it bloody well better not
eat those seeds right and that's really
something to be able to control yourself
to make the future real to put off what
you could use today and not just in some
impulsive manner man maybe your kids are
starving to death you think we are not
touching the seeds that we need to the
future and for human beings to have
discovered that and then to also have
figured out that we could bargain with
the future it's like man that's
something and I think that that I think
that the stories that are laid out in
this book actually describe at least in
part the process by which that occurred
the always stories begin with Genesis
2:4 this is the account of the heavens
and the earth wind so there's two real
creation stories at the beginning the
newer one which is the first one and the
older one which is the second one and
the older one begins in Chapter two and
that's the story that we're going to
that we are getting into now Adam and
Eve are in that can enable know what the
Tower of Babel in the yahwist strand
Exodus numbers along and there's some of
the priestly version in there too as
well as the Ten Commandments well there
are some lovely representations of a
paradise this is a Garden Earthly
Delights what's his name say the boss
yes I wrote it was boss he has a crazy I
mean if you how he didn't get burnt at
the stake is absolutely beyond me I mean
you know some of you know about salvador
deli i suppose most of you do I mean
delis a compared to Hieronymous
Bosch man
you could spend because there's three
pieces of this particular painting you
could spend a very bizarre and surreal
looking at that painting I don't know
what it was with Bosch but he was some
sort of creature that only popped up
once and probably for the best and so
there's been very many representations
of paradise I mean god only knows what
that is it's like I could probably guess
but I won't
and then look I mean that's that's
that's the lion lying down with the lamb
right so that's this idea that's maybe
projected back in time that there was a
time or maybe will be a time when when
that the horrors of life are no longer
necessary for life itself to exist right
and the horrors of life are of course
that everything eats everything else and
that everything dies and that
everything's born and that the whole
bloody place is at charnel-house and
it's it's a catastrophe from beginning
to end and this is this is the vision of
it being other than that and you know
there's a strong idea this is also in
implicit in the alchemical ideas and I
think it's also implicit in the
Scientific Revolution that human beings
can interact with reality in such a way
so that the tragic and evil elements of
it can be mitigated and so that we can
move somewhat closer to a state that
might be characterized Oh that's
obviously imagistic but it might be
characterized by something like that
where we have the benefits of actual
existence without all of the catastrophe
that seems to go along with it and Carl
Jung when he wrote about the emergence
of alchemy or the emergence of science
from alchemy he thought of science as
being motivated by a dream because for
Jung dream was the dream was the
manifestation of the instincts it was
the boundary between the instincts and
thinking said well science is nested
inside a dream and the dream is that if
we investigated the structures of
material reality with sufficient
attention and truth that we could then
learn enough about material reality to
alleviate suffering right to produce the
Philosopher's Stone to make everybody
wealthy to make everybody healthy to
make everyone live as long as they
wanted to live or perhaps forever that's
the goal to alleviate the catastrophe of
existence and that that idea the idea
that mysteries the solution to the
mysteries of life that might enable us
to develop such a substance or let's say
a multitude of substances provided the
motive for
for the development of science and
you'll trace that the development of
that mode of force really over a
thousand years and if you were
interested in reading his books on
alchemy which are extraordinarily
difficult and that's really saying
something about young because all of his
books are difficult and then the books
on alchemy they kind of take a quantum
leap that's actually very small leap so
I shouldn't say that they take a massive
leap into a whole different dimension of
complexity but that's what he was trying
to get at he went back into the
alchemical texts and interpreted them as
if they were the dream on which science
was founded Newton was an alchemist by
the way I mean you know goddesses are
certainly well supported by the
historical fact science did emerge out
of alchemy the question is what were the
alchemists up to and they were trying to
produce the Philosopher's Stone and that
was the universal medical meant for
mankind's pathology Jung felt that what
had happened was that you know
Christianity had promised that the
cessation of suffering promised it for a
thousand years and yet suffering went on
unabated and at the same time
Christianity had attempted to really put
emphasis on spiritual development let's
say at the expense of material
development right thinking of material
development as something akin to a sin
trying to get a control of impulsivity
and all the things that went along with
a to embodied existence there was a
reason for it but that by about a
thousand AD the European mind somewhat
educated by that point somewhat able to
concentrate on a single point perhaps
because of a very long history of
intense religious training turned its
dream to the unexplored material world
and thought well you know the spiritual
Redemption that we've been seeking
didn't appear to produce the result that
was promised or intended and so maybe
there's another place that we should
look and that was in the damned material
world right which which which was
supposed to be at least according to
some elements of classic thinking
nothing but the creation of the devil so
but the point I'm making is that you
know it's very difficult to
underestimate the amount of human
motivation that's embedded in the
attempt to alleviate suffering to
eradicate disease to help people live a
healthy a healthy life and that's the
disease obviously but to live a long
life as well and
make things as peaceful as possible I
mean you can be cynical about people and
you can talk about them as motivated by
power and being corrupt in all of those
things and all of those things are true
but you shouldn't throw away the baby
with the bathwater because we have been
striving for a very long time to set
things right and we've done actually not
too bad a job of it for half starving
crazy insect ridden chimpanzees with
life spans of 50 to 70 years so you know
we could deserve a bit of sympathy for
our position as far as I'm concerned so
[Applause]
some other representations this one I
like the one on the left
that's paradise has a walled garden and
that's what paradise means it's paradise
I which is I don't remember the language
it's it's it's a it's a it's associated
with Persian paradise that means walled
garden and why a walled garden well it
goes back to the chaos order idea so
this is where God puts man and woman
after the creation in a walled garden
well the wall is culture and order and
the garden is nature and the idea is the
proper human habitat is nature and
culture imbalance as well we like
Gardens well why because well they're
not completely covered with weeds and
mosquitoes and black flies right so
they're civilized a little bit but still
within that civilization nature in its
more benevolent guys is encouraged to
flourish and people find that
rejuvenating and so the idea that
paradise the proper habitat of a human
being is a walled garden is a good one
and it's walled because well you want to
keep things out right I mean raccoons
for example if you want to keep those
things out man even though it's
impossible and you know you don't you
don't want well there's all sorts of
things you don't want your garden like
snakes walls don't seem to be much use
against them but the idea that paradise
is a walled garden is is a an echo back
to the chaos order idea walls culture
right garden nature so the proper human
habitat is a properly tended garden now
the radical left-leaning anti-theist
environmentalists tend to make the case
that
the predations of the Western capitalist
system are consequence of the injunction
that was delivered in Genesis by God to
man to go out and dominate the earth
David Suzuki has talked a lot about this
by the way they believe that that
statement has given rise to our
inappropriate assumption that we have
the right to exert control over the
world and that that's what's turned us
into these terrible predatory monsters
sometimes described as cancers on the
face of the earth or viruses that have
inhabited the entire ecosystem who are
doing nothing but what wandering
everywhere and wreaking havoc as rapidly
as we possibly can which is another
perspective on the essential element of
humankind that I find absolutely
deplorable I mean if you look at the
historical record for example even
casually you'll find out that as early
as as late as the late 1800s 1895
thereabouts
Thomas Huxley who was Aldous Huxley's
grandfather and a great defender of
Darwin prepared a report for the British
government on oceans sustainability and
his conclusion was fish away guys man
there's so many fish out there the
oceans are so inexhaustible that no
matter how hard humanity tried for for
any number of years the probability that
we could do more than put a dent in what
was out there was a zero now Huxley
turned out to be wrong he didn't realize
that our population was going to spike
so dramatically partly because we got a
little bit rich and our children stopped
dying at the rate of like 60 percent
before they were one years old and you
know we actually managed to populate the
earth with a few people but it wasn't
really until 1960 or so that we woke up
to the fact that there were so many of
us that we actually had to start paying
attention to what we were doing to the
planet and that's like what 50 years ago
well we've just started to develop the
technology or the wherewithal to
understand that the whole world might be
well considered a garden and we need to
live inside the proper balance between
culture and order or culture and and and
chaos before that we were spending all
of our time just trying not to die
and usually very unsuccessfully so so I
don't agree with that interpretation of
the opening sections of Genesis I don't
believe that it's given human being the
right to act as super predators on the
planet I think that instead the proper
environment for human beings is
presented quite properly as a garden and
that the role of people and that's
explicitly stated in in the second story
in Adam and Eve was to tend the garden
and that means to make the proper
decisions and to make the sure that
everything thrives in flourishes and and
so that it's good for the things that
are living there that aren't just people
but also good for the people too so fine
I think we can we could at least note
that that's a slightly different take on
the story than the ultimately cynical
interpretation that's so commonly put
forward today now inside that wall
garden is a couple of trees and Adam and
Eve and some animals and all of that and
unfortunately the tree happens to have a
snake wrapped around it now that's an
interesting thing we're going to talk
about that a lot and the snake in both
of these representations is no ordinary
snake say it's got a human head and it's
got a human head there too so whatever
that snake is well let's forget about
looking at this from a religious
perspective like if you can just imagine
that you're an anthropologist we've
never seen this image before it's like
what do you see well you see walls and
you see something a fairly Pleasant
enclosure and then you see a tree and
people are eating from the tree but the
tree has a snake in it that has a human
head and so then you might think well
what's a snake with a human head and
then you'd think well it's half snake
and half human that's hardly revelatory
it's just self evidence so whatever that
snake is isn't just a snake it's snake
and human or it's it's its snake and
partakes in whatever human beings are
and that's very important so we'll
continue we'll consider that later and
you see the same thing here and and you
see in this particular version there's
the head this one also has wings and so
this is a winged snake sort of like a
dragon and so it curls on the ground
like a reptile and it's got an aerial
aspect or a spiritual aspect so here
it's a snake which is like the lowest
form of of reptilian life say
something that crawls on the ground it's
something that's human and something
that's spiritual at the same time and it
inhabits the tree which look a lot like
magic mushrooms by the way and you can
look that up if you want that's quite an
interesting little rabbit hole to wander
down if you're curious about it but but
there's an idea here too is that there
was something in the garden at the
beginning of time that was like a snake
that was like a person that was like
something that was winged it was
something spiritual so it's spiritual
human and reptilian all at the same time
and it's the animating spirit of the
tree okay so keep that in mind thus the
heavens and the earth were finished this
is in relationship to Genesis one and
all the host of them and on the seventh
day God ended his work which he had made
and he rested on the seventh day from
all his work which he had made and God
blessed the seventh day and sanctified
it because that in it he had rested from
all his work which God created the need
that's wisdom in that one - I think the
idea of the Sabbath you know because one
of the things I've worked with a lot of
people who were hyper conscientious and
thing about hyper conscientious people
is that they'll just work til they die
and that's actually not very productive
because then they're dead and they can't
work and so what you have to do with
hyper conscientious people is you have
to say well I know you'd rather do
nothing but work and maybe you're just
as guilty as you can possibly be when
you're not working but let's figure out
what you're up to and what you're up to
in all probability is the attempt to be
productive in the least problematic
longest sustaining possible manner and
that might mean you have to take a rest
and so one of the things I used to work
with lawyers with people who had risen
to the top of large law firms and they
were hyper productive types they're
often you know trying to hit their
impossible quota for yearly hours and
and burning themselves to a frazzle as a
consequence and one of the things that
we used to do was he couldn't work fewer
hours because that a day that just
didn't work but what we did was we have
them take more time off you know like a
four-day weekend every two months or
something that was plotted out into the
future and then we track their billable
hours which is the degree of
productivity it would actually increase
so that was so cool because you could
take hard-working people and you could
say look you know take a break why well
because you'll be more productive if you
take a break no that couldn't possibly
be like I should just work flat out all
the time it's like
to test that out you take a break now on
that it's like well what happened was
their productivity would increase often
by 10% so there's a there's wisdom here
too which is okay and this is alludes to
the Adam and Eve story near the end
you're self-conscious you discover the
future you have to work well then the
question is how much should you work and
one answer is you better bloody well
work all the time because no matter how
much work you do you're not solving your
problems they're coming along man and
you can stack up all the money you want
you can stack up all the wealth you want
it is not going to protect you in the
final analysis so you better be hitting
the ground running and you better run
flat out all the time well what happens
if you do that well then you die that's
not a good solution so maybe you should
rest and so how does that rest get
instantiate it well it's not easy to
tell but one way to do it let's say
conceptually is to say look even God had
the rest one day a week and so you don't
have to be so presumptuous to assume
that if God had dressed one day a week
that maybe you know you are allowed to
work non-stop without a break at all you
know and I think our culture has slipped
into that in quite a dangerous way
because everything is open all the time
and I mean I find that just as
convenient as the rest of you but you
know it's so strange to talk to modern
people because one of the things they
always tell you we say well how are you
and what do they always say they don't
say good they don't say bad they say
busy like yeah well okay this is where
Genesis 2 starts and we finally got
there these are the generations of the
heavens and of the earth when they were
created in the day that the Lord God
made the earth in the heavens and every
plant of the field before it was in the
earth and every herb of the field before
it grew for the Lord God had not caused
it to rain upon the earth and there was
not a man to till the ground but there
went up a mist from the earth and
watered the whole face of the ground and
the Lord God formed man of the dust of
the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and man
became a living soul well you know
there's some archaic thinking and there
the breath is life right that's psyche
that's spirit that's inspiration that's
respiration that's that's also citizens
it's numa like pneumatic
hire its its breath and the reason that
people associated life with breath well
that's not so foolish you know I mean
you're breathing man and something you
do all the time and when you die you
start breathing and so the idea that
there's something integral to life about
breathing it's a perfectly reasonable
supposition it actually happens to be
very true and now then to associate the
act of creation with the act of first of
all inspiration and respiration and and
the breathing of life into something
that was inanimate is is well what do
you expect for a one-sentence
description it's not a bad one sentence
description you know so and the Lord God
planted a garden eastward in Eden and
Eden means well watered place and that's
particularly relevant I suppose if
you're a desert dweller right because
the issue there is can you get enough
water to make things grow and so the the
walled garden which is paradise is also
Eden which is a well watered place and
water has the element of chaos we
already saw that in relationship to
Genesis one where the underlying chaos
was often assimilated symbolically to
water and so the idea too is that a
certain amount of chaos has to be
brought into the order in order for it
to be fruitful and you can see that in
the form of allowing in the water and
out of the ground made the Lord God to
grow every tree that is pleasant to the
sight and good for food The Tree of Life
also in the midst of the garden and the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
so two trees are marked out among the
rest one is the Tree of Life and one is
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil now you know you know when you read
something like that if you're thinking
about it that you're in a metaphorical
space now we've got to be careful about
metaphors because you know I could say
yeah that the chaos order idea is a
metaphor but then I also said oh wait a
second it's a metaphor but it's also
what your brain is adapted to and so you
know let's just not be pushing the idea
that it's merely a metaphor too hard and
the same thing is here is happening here
these are metaphors the tree of life
when the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil but that doesn't exactly mean
that they're mere metaphors because
sometimes as I mentioned before and as
if you have a set of things and you
abstract out from them a common element
you can make a strong case that the
common element is
more real than the set of things from
which you extracted it that's the whole
utility in abstraction why would you
bother with it otherwise if you can't
take a set of things and say look
there's something in common across the
set of things it's more important than
the differences between them then you
wouldn't bother abstracting at all and
so the Tree of Life and the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil are
abstractions now one of the questions is
this is a tough one man I've been trying
tried to figure out for a long time why
a fruit and something you eat would be
associated with the transformations of
psychology because that's basically what
happens in the Adam and Eve story why
would it be something that you eat now
Eric Newman who is one of Ewing students
had written a fair bit about this and
got a fair ways with it he said well you
know we do have noted we've noticed
forever that the act of eating
especially if you're hungry especially
if you're starving produces a rapid
spiritual transformation right I mean
some of you this is worth knowing you
probably have a Crabby partner or child
because everyone does and one thing you
might try is that if they get erratic
during the day and you know get all
volatile about nothing at all just give
them something to eat
really I'll tell you man made this sauce
if I do this with my clinical clients
all the time it's like they say well I
fly off the handle at the littlest
things like okay yeah just try this for
a week when you're crabby and
unreasonable eat a piece of cheese or
eat a peanut butter sandwich eat
something that's high protein high fat
and then just wait ten minutes and see
if you're sane and you'll find out that
you're saying after you eat so often
that you just can't believe how crazy
you are when you're hungry
look here's it's really absolutely
bloody remarkable so I'm telling you try
this
it'll-it'll especially if you don't eat
breakfast this will change your life and
so here's a practical bit of information
for you too for all of you
antisocial types who are going to end up
in prison so if you're in prison and you
want to go on parole okay so you have to
go in front of the judge and tell them
why you're not going to do it again so
here's the deal here's the deal it
doesn't really matter what you did and
it doesn't really matter what you
promise what matters is whether you see
the judge before lunch or after lunch
because if you see the judge after lunch
probability that you'll get parole is
60% higher yeah right that is just like
so never have an argument with your
partner when you're hungry or when
they're hungry especially if you want
something from them it's like here's the
sandwich they'll eat it then they'll be
happy then you can manipulate them
because before that man no so you know
it's not that unreasonable to think that
there's a spirit in food because food
rejuvenates and it just doesn't
rejuvenate you physically it rejuvenates
you spiritually and then of course
there's the other things that we consume
that aren't exactly like food that have
a walloping spiritual impact like
alcohol let's say which is a spirit and
is regarded Dionysius right I mean it's
the god of the vine and the god of the
vine possesses you and makes you act all
the fun ways that alcohol makes you act
you know the fun ways that you regret
the next day and so there's the
spiritual element of that too and and
then but there's something even deeper
that I think is so cool that's
associated with food and information
because the story of Adam and Eve
represents the fruit as producing a
psychological transformation and so the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
is an abstraction across trees and it's
trying to say here's something that's
common across trees it's it's a fruit
that's common across trees it's
something like that and so the fruit
across its common across trees is
something you might call food fair
enough that's a generalization but
here's something that's even more cool
the food that's stable across the entire
domain of food isn't food it's
information its information and we use
the same bloody circuits in our brain to
forage for information that squirrels
use to forage for food but animals used
to forage for food it's the same circuit
and why is that because we figured out
that knowing where things is knowing
where the food is is more important than
having the food and so so knowing where
the food is is a form of massive food
information is a form of meta food and
once you have well that's why we're
information foragers and so once you
grasp that and and that ideas is
embedded into the story of Adam and Eve
so whatever it is that they ingest is a
form
meta food it's it's infinite information
and and you know we'll trade food for
information right so if you're stuck on
the edge of the highway and you know
your your hoods up and you're you're
going places thing has turned into a
pile of junk that you don't understand
and somebody pulls beside you up beside
you in their mechanic and they point to
something to say well just put that wire
back on there you'll immediately give
them a sandwich right or you'll offer
them something in return you know what I
mean because they've provided you with
information that has value and it has
value because it actually provides you
with energy because information provides
you with energy because otherwise why
would we bother with it and so food
provides energy but so does information
and so there's the there's the idea of
food that you abstract from everything
you can eat but then there's the idea of
what you could abstract from all sources
of food and the answer to that would be
information and the trees that are being
referred to in Adam and Eve are these
method trees they're not ordinary trees
just like paradise is no ordinary place
like Adam and Eve are no ordinary people
and just like the logos that God is
using at the beginning of time is no
ordinary conception and these aren't
they're not metaphors there more than
metaphors there I think of them as hyper
realities it's something like that is
there more real than what you see there
more real than the reality that presents
itself to you and lots of things are
like that right numbers are like that we
wouldn't think or abstract if there
weren't things that were more real than
what we can see so what's most real well
that's partly what we're trying to
figure out and out of the ground make
the Lord God to grow every tree that is
pleasant to the sight and good for food
The Tree of Life also in the midst of
the garden and the tree of knowledge of
good and evil and a river went out of
Eden to water the garden and from thence
it was parted and became into foreheads
that's produced a tremendous amount of
speculation now you know the Garden of
Eden is also the holy city that's
another way of thinking about or it's
Jerusalem right or it's the ideal state
which could be the ideal city or to be
an ideal state of being or could be the
ideal site here if all of those things
stacked up at the same time right this
is a Mandela and this is the Mandela
form that people what we call
hypothesised that constituted the
structure of paradise you notice it's
got this cross form that's eaten itself
and there's the
the center of Eden and there's the
rivers those are rivers not snakes those
are the rivers that go out of it and
they're turned into these mandela images
that are representative of what Jung
described as the self which would be the
center element of being that he
associated of conscious being that he
associated with divinity I would say but
also with the idea of the holy city so
I'm just showing you that to show you
what where the imagination has taken
ideas of paradise so the name of the
first river is Pisan that is which
compasses the whole land of havilah
whether is gold and the gold of that
land is good there's bdellium and the
Onyx stone and the name of the second
river is gijón the same is it that
compasseth the whole land of ethiopia
and the name of the third river is heady
kal or Hideki I don't know that is it
which goes towards the east of Assyria
and the fourth River is the Euphrates so
there's this strange intermingling there
of geography with mythical geography
right which you see happen fairly
frequently in the books and the Lord God
took the man and put him in the Garden
of Eden to dress it and keep it okay so
that's that's a good that's a good
command that's what you're supposed to
do is take care of the damn thing with a
lot of work to make right took a whole
week and the Lord God commanded the man
saying of every tree of the garden thou
mayest freely eat but of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil thou shalt
not eat of it for in the day that thou
eatest thereof thou shalt surely die
well there's a sponge of questions there
that people have been puzzling they're
puzzling over for a long time gaudy he's
tricky character in the story of Adam
and Eve it's like okay if we can't eat
the damn thing well why put in the
garden to begin with that would be one
question and you made us and then you
told us not to eat this knowing
perfectly well that the first thing we
were going to do is eat it because
people are of exactly that type which is
that if you say to them with their
insatiable curiosity this is all fine
and nice but over here is something you
should never look at and then you leave
the room it's like everybody is over
there trying to figure what the hell
that thing is instantly right because
we're curious curious curious curious
creatures and so you have to wonder
exactly what God was up to here and
there's Gnostic speculation that the
original God
was not really a very good God he was
kind of an unconscious evil god and that
he wanted his creation to be unconscious
and so forbade them from developing
consciousness and that it was a higher
God who and maybe in the form of the
serpent who tempted human beings towards
consciousness and you know that that
idea got scrubbed out of classic
Christianity pretty early although
there's something that's interesting
about it and there are remnants of it in
different forms that stayed inside the
story like the idea that the fall was
you know a terrible tragedy but on the
other hand it was the precondition for
the greatest event in history which was
the birth of Christ and the redemption
of mankind and so it's complicated let's
put it that way god only knows what God
was up to but you know this is a good
example of that ambivalence to me again
that it's an indication of the
sophistication of the people who put
these stories together I also consider
this somewhat miraculous because you
know if you were just a simple
propagandist of sorts you wouldn't leave
this sort of complexity in the text you
just get rid of that because if you're a
propagandist everything is supposed to
make sense along the ideological plane
and here God is supposed to be good it's
like well we better get there to that
line because something's up with it and
obvious what it is but that isn't what
people did and to me that indicates that
that they were doing two things as they
were trying not to be too careless with
the traditions that they were handed
they they were they were touching them
at their peril they were very careful
with them and also that they were
actually trying to understand what was
going on because why otherwise keep this
why not just simplify it or maybe just
to tribute this to the devil that would
be easier and having God do it but and
the Lord God said it is not good that
man should be alone I will make help
meet for him none of the ground the Lord
God formed every beast of the field at
every fall of the air and brought them
unto Adam to see what he would call them
and whatsoever Adam called every living
creature that was the name thereof and
Adam gave names to all the cattle in the
fall of cattle means animals basically
and to the fall of the air and every
beast of the field but for Adam there
was not found to help meet for him okay
well a couple of things there
speculations number one it's like why
does God care what Adam calls the
animals and the answer that seems to be
it's associated again with the magic of
speech right so that we know according
to the story that human beings were
already made in the image of God and
that God used language in order to call
order forth from chaos and that human
beings were made in that image and so
there's an echo of that here even though
it's from an independent tradition in
the echo is the thing isn't quite real
till you name it and that's quite and
that's that's an interesting thing and
we don't exactly know how far that
extends it's certainly the case that
like seeing things often exist in a
strange potential form interconnected
form where everything's confusing like a
massive confusion before you put your
finger on it name it what's going on
here you name it it's like it it carves
it out from all that underlying chaos it
makes it into Agrippa Belen today that
you can then contend with and you might
say well it was real before you named it
it's like well yes it was real before
you named it the same way things are
there when there's no one there to
perceive them and it isn't obvious how
things are there when you're not there
to perceive them I'll tell you something
bloody weird about perception you can
look this up at John Wheeler John
Leader's a physicist so here's a really
cool thing let's say you go outside at
night and you look up and you see a star
and like so a photon from That star
enters your eye then maybe that photon
has been cruising along for like 30
million years do you know that that
photon would not have been emitted from
that star at that time if your eye
wasn't there at that time to receive it
you think well how the hell can that
because it happened 20 million years ago
it's like well I don't know how it can
be to tell you the truth but I know that
John Wheeler has done a very good job of
detailing out why that's true and
necessarily true and so in wheeler is
also the physicists who develop the
notion of it from bit and he believes
that the world is best construed as a
the potential of the world is best
construed as a place of information it's
something like leading information and
at what consciousness does is transform
the latent Internet in information into
something like concrete reality he
doesn't mean that metaphorically and one
of the cases that he makes in that
regard is this story that I just told
you is that the photon couldn't have
left
from where it was unless it had a place
to go now it's it's complicated and
confusing because from the perspective
of a beam of light from a photon there
is no time and there's no distance from
one point to another when of course
that's completely impossible to
understand - but from the perspective of
a photon the universe is completely flat
perpendicular to the direction that the
photon is traveling so it's there and
here at the same time for us it's not
it's like 20 million years ago but for
the photon it's it's all here and now so
anyways the reason I'm telling you all
that is because the relationship between
consciousness and reality is by no means
straightforward it is seriously not
straightforward and physicists
physicists debate what the relationship
is between consciousness and reality and
they debate about what the sort of
phenomena that I just described mean and
I'm not really qualified to enter into
that debate because I'm not a physicist
but I do know and I've read it for a bit
of wheeler as but as much of it as I can
understand and I do at least know that
that's what he claimed and I also know
that that claim is not that's the claim
that's taken seriously among physicists
of the caliber of the physicists who can
understand wheeler so that's pretty
interesting so anyways there is emphasis
again on this importance of naming in
order to make things real you know and
sometimes people won't name things just
so they don't become real so you know if
you're if you have a relationship which
undoubtedly you do and it has problems
which undoubtedly it does you bloody
well know that lots of times there's
something under the carpet that no one
wants to name and everybody's thinking
well as long as we don't name it it's
not really there and in some sense it
really isn't there because you could act
as if it's not there and get away with
it at least for short periods of time it
sees you name that thing it's like you
give it form and it's there and no one
can ignore it and that's annoying
because then you have to deal with it or
Noor or face the consequences but the
reason I'm telling you that is because
we have a an intuition even that we can
have things not exist by not naming them
you name it and it comes forward with
staggering clarity and it's not as if
naming it is the only thing that gives
it reality but it is something like it
sharpens it brings it into focus and
gives it borders and barriers and
borders and boundaries and so anyways
gods interested enough in what Adam has
to
say that he has him name all the animals
and that sort of makes them into animals
now there's more to the linguistic story
than that so the social psychologist
Roger Brown was one of them studied this
really interesting phenomena which is
associated with relationship between
perception and action you know how a kid
will call a particular animal a cat well
the word cat is very short like the word
dog and it turns out that you know you
could think that we could perceive cats
as multicellular organisms like we could
see the cells we could see the molecules
we could see the atoms we could see or
we could see the ecosystem that the cat
is part of but we don't or maybe the
broader mammalian classification that
it's part of we could perceive that as
the unit of perception but we don't we
perceive things at the level of cat and
you can tell the perceptual level that
people naturally perceive that which
doesn't seem to be socio-culturally
determined to any great degree by the
way because the words are often short
and easily remembered and early learned
and so there's this level of analysis
out of all the possible levels of
analysis that the world does exist that
we perceive it at a certain level of
analysis and that level of analysis
seems to have something to do with the
world's functional utility for us at
that level and the perception at that
level and the naming at that level gives
things a reality at that level you know
because the thing about things is that
they're not easily separable from other
things they tangled together in all
sorts of strange ways and yet when we
cast our eye and and use our language to
orient ourselves in the world we cut
things up into discrete discriminable
objects that we can then utilize and
there's something about that that makes
them real in a way that they're
interconnected potential the
interconnected potential that they were
before that that it's not it's not real
in the same way at least I think it's
even less real I think that's the right
way of thinking about it even though
it's not completely unreal but it's an
echo atoms a little God at that point a
little God the Father and God's already
done the groundwork but Adam has to come
along and says say well that's a cat
it's like poof whatever that is is now a
cat and that's
dog and that's a sheep and you know it
gives them it gives them something like
pragmatic form but for Adam there was
not found to help meet for him and the
Lord God caused a deep sleep to fall
upon Adam and he slept and he and God
took one of his ribs and closed up the
flesh instead thereof and the rib which
the Lord God had taken from man made he
a woman and brought her unto the man and
Adam said this is now bone of my bones
and flesh of my flesh she shall be
called woman because she was taken out
of man therefore shall a man leave his
father and his mother and shall cleave
unto his wife and they shall be one
flesh that's a walloping statement to
put in there at the end of those three
sentences and therefore comes as
somewhat of a surprise but there's an
injunction there well it's a good
injunction man you'll tell you people
who don't do that they have a hell of a
time in their marriage and so this is a
good thing to know if you are married or
if you're planning to get married is
like you know we have very strong
orientation towards our parents and for
good reason it's like the injunction
here is that secondary since you're
married and and failure to do that makes
your marriage collapse and then you
deserve it to collapse - as far as I'm
concerned because it's a reflection of
your pathological immaturity and your
unwillingness to extract yourself from
the you know tellin like grip of parents
who are a little bit too much on the
interfering side but the injunction
there's a deep injunction here it's very
complicated so one of the ideas is that
the original Adam wasn't a man like like
a separate man it was more like a
hermaphroditic being and in that him
alfred etic being there was a kind of
undifferentiated perfection and then
that was split into male and female and
then that part of the goal of human
beings is to reunite that as the
singular unity that reestablishes the
initial perfection and that's actually
the goal of marriage from a spiritual
perspective and you could read about
that if you read young because he wrote
quite a bit about that so lovely it's
such a good idea so I had these friends
that went to Sweden to get married they
were northern they were from northern
Alberta but his heritage their both
their Heritage's were Sweden Swedish and
in this ceremony they did this cool
thing yes they were being married and
they had two
hold a candle up between them right
while they were being married and you
think well okay what's the candle that's
a source of light the source of
illumination right the source of
enlightenment it's the candle that you
put on Christmas trees in Europe so it's
the light that emerges in the darkness
in the depth of winter it's a symbol of
life in darkness it's the reemergence of
the Sun that the at the darkest coldest
time of the year which is also
associated symbolically with the birth
of Christ for all sorts of complicated
reasons and so the candles all that and
then the next question is why do you
hold it above you and the answer is
because what's above you is what you're
below too
so it's single simplify something
transcendent and so why do you both hold
on to it well because you're both
supposed to hold on to the light right
and you're supposed to be subordinate to
the light and so you ask well who's in
charge in marriage well the light that's
the idea so you come together as one
thing you no longer two things
it isn't what's good for you and it's
not what's good for your wife it's
what's good for the marriage and the
marriage is about the combined being
which is the reassembly of the original
hefferman herma frenetic hermaphroditic
being at the beginning of time that's
the idea
and that's all packed into like these
four sentences and you know there's been
well all of these sentences have
tremendous history of interpretation
associated with them right it's just
endless and endless and endless and
that's one of the lines and so it's also
an antidote to the idea that women taken
out of man which is obviously the
reverse of the biological process by the
way makes women in some sense
subordinate to man that is not built
into this text I don't see that at all
is built into the text and there's
something else that's associated with it
too and there's an idea that you know in
in Sleeping Beauty you know what
Sleeping Beauty goes to sleep and the
reason she goes to sleep is because you
have to remember what happens is she has
parents who are quite old and so they're
pretty desperate to have a child like so
many people are now and they only have
one child like so many people do now and
they wanted it happen to this child
because like hey it's a miracle and
there's only one of them and so she's
the princess and so it's like
we're not letting anything around here
so they have a big christening party
right and they invite everybody but they
don't invite Maleficent and Maleficent
is the terrible mother she's nature
she's like the thing that goes bump in
the night she's the devil herself
so to speak she's everything that you
don't want your child to encounter so
the king and queen saying well we just
want to invite her to the christening
it's like good luck with that
that's an eatable story right the
eatable mother is the mother who devours
her child by refusing by over protecting
him or her so that instead of being
strengthened by an encounter with the
terrible world they're weakened by too
much protection and then when they're
let out into the world they cannot live
and that's the story of Sleeping Beauty
and that's what the king and queen do
and they apologize to the two Maleficent
when she first shows up and say well you
know they have a bunch of half-witted
excuses why they don't invite her we
forgot like I don't think so you know
you don't forget something like that and
she kind of makes that point it's right
the whole horror of life you don't
forget about that when you have a child
that's for sure you might wish that it
would stay at bay but you do not forget
about it the question is do you invite
it to the party and the answer is it
bloody well depends how unconscious you
want your child to be and if you want
your child to be unconscious well then
you have the added advantage but maybe
they won't leave home and so you can
take advantage of them for the rest of
your sad life instead of going off to
find something to do for yourself well
and then of course you can take revenge
on them if they do have any any what
would you call impetus towards courage
that you sacrificed yourself 30 years
ago and want to stamp out as soon as you
see it developing your child that's
another thing that would be quite
pleasant and so that's what happens in
Sleeping Beauty yeah well none of this
is pleasant and nothing that happens in
that story is pleasant so Sleeping
Beauty she's naive as hell they put her
out in the forest and have her raised by
these three like goody-two-shoes fairies
that are also completely devoid of any
real potency and power right there's no
nothing Maleficent about them and then
the first idiot Prince that wanders by
she falls in love with so badly that she
has post-traumatic stress disorder when
he rides off on his horse great that's
what happened and then she then she goes
into the castle and she's all freaked
out because she met the love of her life
for like five minutes for God's sake and
you know that's when the
spinning wheel that's the Wheel of Fate
pops up and she pricks her finger right
I try to get rid of all the spinning
wheels they try to get rid of all the
wheels of fate with her pointed end but
she finds it poke pricks her fingers and
frame her and falls down unconscious
while she wants to be unconscious and no
bloody wonder she was protected her
whole life she's so damn naive that her
first love affair just about kills her
she wants to go to sleep and never wake
up and so that's exactly what happens
and then she has to wait for the prince
to come and rescue her well you think
how sexist can you get that story well
seriously because that's that's the way
that that would be read and in the
modern world it's like she doesn't need
a prince to rescue her that's why I
Disney made frozen that absolutely
appalling piece of rubbish so you know
you can say you can say well the
princess doesn't need a prince to rescue
her but you know that's a boneheaded way
of looking at the story because the
prince isn't just a man who's coming to
rescue the woman and believe me he's got
his own problems right he's got a whole
goddamn dragon he has to contend with
but but the prince also represents the
woman's own consciousness the
consciousness is presented very
frequently in story that's symbolically
masculine as it is with the logos idea
and the idea is that without without
that forward going courageous
consciousness a woman herself will drift
into unconsciousness and terror and so
you can read it as well the woman who's
sleeping needs a man to wake her up and
of course just like a man needs a woman
to wake him up it's the same damn thing
that's the dragon fight in Sleeping
Beauty but it's also the case that if
she's only unconscious all she can do is
lay there and sleep like the sleep of
the naive and Damned she has to wake and
wake herself up and and bring her own
consciousness or own masculine
consciousness into the forefront so that
she can survive in the world of course
women are trying to do that like mad but
that's partly what's represented in the
story like that and that's partly what's
implicit in this idea is that unless the
woman is taken out of man so to speak
then she isn't a human being she's just
a creature and that's partly what's
embedded in this story so you don't want
to read it as a patriarchal
you want to read anything that way so
really it's it really it's yeah I will I
won't bother without but really we can
do better than that man therefore shall
a man leave his father and his mother
and shall cleave unto his wife and they
shall be one flesh
it's like ya seeing the other thing
about marriage this is really worth
knowing too is that I've learned this in
part from reading young it's like what
do you do when you get married that's
easy you take someone who's just as
useless and horrible as you are and then
you shackle yourself to them and then
you say we're not running away no matter
what happens yeah well that that's
perfect because then you don't get to
run away and the thing is is like if you
can run away you can't tell each other
the truth because if you tell someone
the truth about you and they don't run
away they weren't listening and so if
you don't have someone around the can't
run away then you can't tell them the
truth and so that's part of the purpose
of the marriage it's like okay okay I'll
bet on you you bet on me it's a losing
bet we both know that but given our
current circumstances were unlikely to
find anyone better that's for sure
you know there's two things that come
off of that one is you know people are
waiting around to find mr. or mrs. right
it's like here's something to think
about man to put yourself on your feet
right if you went to a party and you
found mr. right and he looked at you and
didn't run away screaming that would
indicate that he wasn't mr. right at all
right it's like the old Nietzsche and
joke if someone loves you that should
immediately disenchant you with them
right right or it's the Woody Allen joke
I never belonged to a club that would
take me as a member so so that's a
that's an interesting that's a very
interesting thing to think about and so
you're going to shackle yourself to
someone who's just as imperfect as you
are and then the issue is you you you
might be in a situation where you can
actually negotiate because you might say
well there's some things about you that
aren't going so right and there's some
things about me that aren't going so
right and we're bloody well stuck with
the consequences for the next 50 years
so we could we can either straighten
this out or we can suffer through it for
the next five decades and you know
people are of this
or that without that degree of
seriousness those problems will not be
solved you'll leave things unnamed
because there's always an ounce like and
it's the same thing when you're living
together with someone you know that
people who live together before they're
married are more likely to get divorced
not less likely and the reason for that
is what exactly are you saying to one
another when you live with each other
just think about it well for now you're
better than anything else I can trick
but I'd like to reserve the right to
trade you in conveniently if someone
bitter happens to stumble into me
well how could how could someone not be
insulted to their core by an offer like
that now they're willing to play along
with it because they're going to do the
same thing with you now well that's
exactly and it's like yeah yeah I know
you're not going to commit to me so that
means you don't value me or our
relationship above everything else but
as long as I get to escape if I need to
then I'm willing to put up with that
it's like that's a hell of a say I mean
you might think how stupid is it to
shackle yourself to someone it's like
it's stupid man there's no doubt about
that
but compared to the alternatives it's
pretty damn good because without that
shackling there are things you will
never ever learn because you'll avoid
them you can always leave and if you can
leave then you don't have to tell each
other the truth it's as simple as that
because you can just leave and then you
don't have anyone you can tell the truth
to so there are some representations of
the idea of the original it's not this
isn't all Adam this is this is an old
Chinese symbol I think it's Fuxi and new
I think I have the pronunciation wrong
but it's really cool see it's see the
snakes down here they're kind of like a
DNA symbol which I find very interesting
and so that's the original cosmic
serpent that's sort of the potential out
of which that emerges and then that's
the differentiation of that into male
and female and so that's like the
predatory unknown that's one way of
thinking about it that's the most
fundamental conception of mankind is
something like that is the predatory
unknown and then the bifurcation of that
into the two fundamental cognitive
elements of human perception masculine
and female and you see the same thing
here this is Chinese this is Egyptian
also extraordinarily old it's the it's
the great serpent that underlies
everything Matt advocating itself into
Isis queen of the underworld and Osiris
king of the king of king of King Pharaoh
king of order you see the same thing in
an old alchemical symbol I love this one
it looks quite a lot like the little
thing that Harry Potter chases around it
yeah and that's not accidental by the
way because the seeker is the thing the
thing that chases this and the seeker
that chases this and catches it wins and
that's a really old idea and how the
hell'd JK Rowling knew that I cannot
figure out because that is a very very
archaic symbol arcane symbol on Google
it's called the round
chaos and the only reference to the
round chaos that I can find on Google is
on my web page and so I have no idea how
Rowling came up with that I mean I know
she looked at a lot of old texts but the
idea that if you play the meta game and
you catch this you win all the games is
exactly right not and that's the motif
for what's the name of that Quidditch
yeah so there's the potential that's
like the potential out of which God made
the world at the beginning of time and
what emerges out of that is some kind of
that's a dragon you know that in the
dragon fight that's partly the serpent
that's in the Garden of Eden and then
that's the manifestation of masculine
and feminine out of that potential
predatory unknown masculine and feminine
it's like a single it's like a single
representation of the evolutionary
history of human cognitive consciousness
so cool and that's also an image of the
ideal it's the union of Sun and Moon and
it's this hyper creature hermaphroditic
it's also the Adam and Eve that existed
at the beginning of time before the fall
and it's the purpose of marriage all of
that as a sacrament all of that in these
images it's just absolutely unbelievable
what images can pack into them and
there's a more classical representations
of Eve being extracted from Adam and
this is a cool line and they were both
naked the man and his wife and we're not
ashamed
well that see someone who wrote that
would only write that like that if they
were surprised that they weren't ashamed
because why would you point it out
otherwise and so there's this intimation
that of two things number one is there
was a point at time in time when human
beings were naked and they weren't
ashamed of it and there is a point of
time which is now where they're naked
and they are ashamed of it and then the
question is well what's the association
with nakedness and shame and that's all
often given a sexual connotation in in
classic interpretations of the Adam and
Eve story because of its association
with nudity I presume but I think it's a
lot more complicated than that so you
think I know I would notice my daughter
she probably won't be very happy that
I'm revealing this in this lecture but
my daughter was never really concerned
about nudity when she was a little kid
all the same to her one way or another
but my son by the time he was three man
that kid was private he his his bedroom
door was shut the bathroom door was shut
it was like get the hell out of here and
that seemed to just happen of its own
accord and you know we had two children
and one was like that the other one
wasn't I didn't think we had much to do
with it at all but it was really
fascinating to watch that emerge in him
and you know that that sense of of
self-consciousness does seem to emerge
in children somewhere around the age of
three and you know that's generally also
when we start thinking that maybe having
your baby wander around naked on a beach
isn't exactly the best idea there's this
there's something like that it's the
nudity and children is generally okay
under some circumstances in public
display we seem to think of that as
merely as acceptable why I don't know
why it stops being acceptable well that
has something to do with sexuality
obviously but it's a very complicated
phenomena but you know that whole nudity
thing is then is a very complicated
thing I mean first of all people are
kind of strange because we're hairless
roughly you know compared to most
animals and we don't know why that is
some people think it's because we lost
our heroin we're wandering around in the
debt in the desert running around in
Africa because we're really really good
runners we can run down animals say like
a human being in good shape can run a
horse to death in a week we can really
run man and a lot of our ancestors the
Kalahari Bushmen still do this they just
run an animal for like until it dies and
that Bushman doesn't die I mean they
also sometimes shoot them with poison
arrows but they can just run them till
they die so we have tremendous endurance
and you and you have to be able to get
rid of a lot of heat if you're going to
run around in the desert so we don't
have much hair that's one explanation
and Buckminster Fuller had an
interesting explanation which was he
thinks that at some point during our
evolution we spend a lot of time near
the water and so we're like fish Apes
something like that well you know we
like to be on the beach and there's lots
of food there and we like to swim and
we're really good at swimming for
terrestrial creatures and we cry salt
tears like some seagoing creatures - and
women have a layer of subcutaneous fat
like some seagoing creatures - and we
have kind of our feet are which are very
odd things are kind of good for flapping
in the water although we can also walk
with them and so he thought that maybe
that adaptation was too
water existence like seals and so forth
like we kind of went back to the ocean
but not quite and so but anyways the
evolution of that hairlessness is an
interesting thing but it certainly does
make us exposed to the world in a way
that animals that have a covering of fur
aren't and then we're upright which is
very strange because most animals aren't
they're on all fours and so they're very
vulnerable parts are protected and not
exposed to view and then of course when
you're standing up nude your your your
visit let's call it your
psychophysiological quality is on
painful display right and people
complain about that all the time you
know if you look at the feminist tack
for example on beauty the idea that
women have eating disorders is directly
attributed to the presence of too many
beautiful women on the cover of
magazines something like that even
though women buy those magazines and
they're attracted to the bandar mood
goes up when they purchase them and if
the if the stimulus was negative the
women would avoid the magazines and not
buy them so as a theory it's a very very
bad one but it's still the case that you
know it's still the case that standards
of beauty shame people and that's for
sure and everyone because if you're not
ugly now man you're going to be at some
point in your life so that's kind of a
rough thing to contend with right it's
it's a rough thing to to know that that
there's an ideal that you could be and
maybe even one swear that you're not
going to be for long or Norden or never
were and it's really an appalling issue
because I think it's harder on women
because women are judged by men more for
their what for their youth and fertility
that's how it turns out from the
evolutionary point of view men are
judged more on their socioeconomic
status by women it's harsh both ways but
so anyways it's you know it's a terrible
thing to to carry the knowledge with you
that you're exposed to the most serious
possible evaluation of the quality of
your being that you can possibly be
exposed to all the time and that that's
further amplified if you're without
clothing and so part of clothing is
protection but a tremendous amount of it
is merely stopping other people from
evaluating you too harshly all the time
it just gets in the way so
anyways this store this this story makes
the case that at some point we would
like that well animals aren't like that
so it seems perfectly plausible at at
some point we weren't like that but at
some point that changed and they were
both naked the man and his wife and
we're not ashamed of a serpent was more
subtle than any beast of the field which
the Lord God had made and he said unto
the woman yea hath God said ye shall not
eat of every tree of the garden I like
this this is um oh I can't remember who
did the edging yell who is it da-rae
yeah DeRay exactly he door a did
etchings for Paradise Lost that are
absolutely remarkable and this is Satan
and this is the snake here and of course
in the Genesis story Satan is weirdly
associated with the snake and I'll tell
you that's a that's a that's a tough one
to sort out because in the story of Adam
and Eve there's no indication whatsoever
that the serpent who tempts Eve is also
Satan the author of all evil and how in
the world those two stories got tangled
together well I think I figured that out
and I'm going to tell you that tonight
but it took a very long time to figure
it out and it's absolutely it's so
bloody brilliant I just can't believe
that people figured it out it's so it's
so unbelievably spectacularly brilliant
and that's a that's a an intimation of
that idea right that there's a kinship
between these two things so anyways the
serpents more subtle than any beast of
the field subtle is an interesting word
this is from the oxford english
dictionary
so because will amplify the word a bit
this is what you do in Union dream
interpretation for example is to kind of
look at the connotations of the concepts
that are associated with the dream
subtle of a person or animal and action
behavior crafty cunning sly treacherous
so it's something that sort of sneaks
along right it's not something that you
really pick up on that easily of a look
or glance sly furtive surreptitious of a
person skillful expert clever of a work
of art mechanical device cleverly made
or designed ingenious well that that's I
think that's all fairly all those terms
so far are fairly well attributed to
snakes I mean they are very cool things
and and they are very well designed
they're quite remarkable and
they're also very subtle on the nature
of or involving careful discrimination
of fine points or fine points difficult
to understand and abstruse of a person
the mind or intellectual activity
intellectual activity characterized by
wisdom and perceptiveness discriminating
discerning and truth that's interesting
because Milton's Satan is also the
intellect and you know you see that very
often you know it's so often the bad
guys an evil scientist right and there's
something about and then you see the
same thing in the Lion King with scar
I mean scars and intellect and arrogant
deceitful intellect there's nothing
stupid about scar he's not wise but he's
the he's the evil voice that's always
whispering in the Kings ear and that's
associated with the pride of the
intellect and the Catholics had warned
warned humanity about the pride of the
intellect for centuries that's partly
what produced somewhat of the schism
between Catholicism and science although
that's much overstated if you look at
the historical record the idea was that
the intellect has its own particular
it's a remarkable faculty let's say it's
the highest angel in God's heavenly
kingdom that's the way that Milton
portrayed it but it's also the thing
that can go most terribly wrong because
intellect the intellect can become
arrogant about its own existence and
accomplishments and it can fall in love
with its own products and that's what
happens when your ideological II
possessed because you end up with a
Dogma like say a human constructed Dogma
in Solzhenitsyn's words that possesses
you completely of which you believe is
100% right right so it eradicate the
necessity for anything transcendent and
so that's the subtil element of the
intellect that's associated symbolically
with the snake in the garden of paradise
of a feeling scent sensation acute and
keen involving distinctions that are
finer delicate especially to such an
extent as to be difficult to discern or
analyze also almost imperceptible and
elusive having little thickness or
breadth thin fine subtil matter now
historical rarefied mouth barely there
at all and the women said unto the
serpent we may eat of the fruit of the
trees of the garden one of
the fruit of the tree which is in the
midst of the garden God this God has
said he shall not eat of it neither
shall you touch it lest you die and the
serpent said to the woman ye shall not
surely die for God doth know in the day
that you eat thereof then your eyes
shall be opened and you shall be as
God's knowing good and evil
sneaky subtle it's a nice story a the
first thing is for instance the instant
implication is well you can't trust God
so that's pretty sneaky and the next is
when he's trying to he's trying to pull
a fast one on you and the next one is
what he's trying to do that because he's
jealous and he doesn't want you to know
things that he knows because that would
be so good and he's lying to you anyways
because you're not going to die and if
you eat it contrary to what you've been
informed then all that's going to happen
is your eyes will be open and you'll be
like God's knowing good and evil that
sounds pretty damn good so you know a
night I mean Eve
but as she no and hold still wonder
she's susceptible to such blandishments
and it's quite interesting too because
out of and Eve God tells Adam and Eve
not to eat the damn fruit but they never
promise not to write so they haven't
promised they've just been told to and
well should they be obedient
well how obedient do you want your
children to be you want them to be
obedient enough so they don't get hurt
but disobedience enough so that they go
up in the world and do something
courageous and they break some rules
that they learn some things and so you
know it's it's it's a very paradoxical
story anyways the serpent one that wins
this round man and so Eve pays attention
to the snake so again we have the same
set of images right we have Adam and we
have Eve we have this tree and we have
this strange serpent that's a
dragon-like form they're a sphinx like
form that's associated with the tree the
snakes eternally associated with the
tree well the snake wasn't eternally
associated with the tree we spent god
only knows how many tens of millions of
years as tree dwelling primates and the
primary or one of our primary predators
we had three primary predators snakes
birds cats and so the snake has been
associated with the tree for a very very
long time and the lesson the snake tells
people is
you bloody well better wake up or
something you don't like will get you
and who's going to be more susceptible
susceptible to paying attention to the
snake and that's going to be Eve and the
reason for that is Eve has offspring and
there's nothing tastier to a snake than
a child and so Eve had every reason to
be self-conscious and neurotic and women
are more self-conscious and neurotic
than men by quite a substantial amount
and that's true cross culturally and it
emerges at puberty and part of the
reason is as far as we can tell is that
women are more sexually vulnerable
they're also smaller so that's a problem
if you're engaged in a physical
alteration but most importantly I think
is that why would you ever assume that a
human females nervous system is adapted
to her or her well-being why wouldn't
you assume instead that her nervous
system is adapted to the female infant
dyad because if it isn't then the
infant's die and so you might take well
women are way more susceptible to
depression and anxiety than men are
that's a hell of a burden to bear and
that's also true cross culturally by the
way and it also kicks in at puberty and
the biggest differences are in
Scandinavia for those of you who think
it's socio-cultural which isn't so but
there's reasons for it you know and it's
also at puberty when men and women start
to become sexually dimorphic in terms of
size and men are way more powerful in
their upper bodies it's incomparably
more powerful and so that makes them a
lot more dangerous and human human
primary human defense mechanism is
punching like with kangaroos for because
there's a mother animals the punch
chimps can punch too but human beings
it's a punch and most of the force and
that is upper-body and shoulder and so a
woman's no match for a man in a fight so
she has every reason to be nervous
especially when you add that to that her
additional sexual vulnerability and the
fact that she has to take care of
extraordinarily dependent infants who
are extremely fragile for a very long
period of time and so she had every and
women are more self-conscious than men
the empirical literature on that is
clear it's associated with trait
neuroticism because self-consciousness
is actually an unpleasant emotion who
wants to be self-conscious if I'm
self-conscious on the stage talking to
you then all of a sudden I can't even
talk to you all I'm doing is thinking
about me and all the things that are
wrong with me and I fall inside myself
it's like self-consciousness
although it's a great gift let's say is
nothing Pleasant its associated
primarily with anxiety so we've had
every reason to pay attention to the
snake that's for sure I think I read
this week that among can't remember
which tribes minute where it was
unfortunately although I did put a
footnote in my new book about this these
were jungled dwelling tribal people 5%
of the adults had been attacked by a
python and a substantial number of
children had been killed by them so
snake predation was no joke it shaped
our evolutionary past and still is no
joke in many places and so we're a tuned
to snakes and the thing is as lynn has
bel pointed out an anthropologist we are
really good at detecting the camouflage
patterns of snakes especially in the
lower half of our visual field and
there's evidence that part of the reason
that human beings have such a cute
vision which means that our eyes opened
let's say is because we were we Co
evolve with snakes and we learned how to
see them and then the price we paid for
seeing was that our brain grew because
you need a lot of brain to be able to
see and the consequence of our brain
growing is one day we woke up and
discovered the future and the future is
where all the snakes might live instead
of where they live right now so there's
that the same thing and the same so
interesting again these images you see
in this one you have the specter of
death in the tree with the snake and the
fruit no fruit is interesting - I
already made the case that there's a
tight linkage between what you eat and
information right a conceptual link as
well as a practical link but it's also
the case that we can see colors and the
question is why and the answer is
because we evolved to see ripe fruit so
in the story of Adam and Eve human
beings are given vision by the snake and
the fruit and that turns out to be
correct so isn't that something and then
you think what role do women play in
relationship to men well first they make
them self conscious let's not ever
forget about that because I would say
the primary role that women have in
relationship to manage to make them
self-conscious and men don't precisely
like that there's nothing that will make
a man more self-conscious than being
rejected and why because why is he
rejected
well obviously mother nature in the
guise of that particular woman have said
you're not so bad for a friend but
there's no reason that your genetic
material should propagate itself into
the future
right well it's not like men are exactly
happy about being me but made self
conscious by women right it's a major
source of continual tension between men
and women and it's no wonder but it's
also the case and this is something
really cool and interesting to know you
know we'd evolved dive divulge guy
whatever that's it diverged we diverged
from the common ancestor between us and
chimpanzees about six million years ago
here's why at least in part chimpanzee
females are non discriminant mater's
they'll mate with any male when they go
into heat which human females don't when
they go into heat then any male is
allowed access now the dominant males
chase the subordinate males away and so
the dominant males are more likely to
leave offspring but it's not because of
the female choice it's not the case with
human beings human females engage in
hypergamy and hypergamy is the ten this
is also to cross culturally and it's
also quite it's just as extensive in
Scandinavia not quite there's a bit of
attenuation but not much women mate
across and up dominance hierarchies
man-made across and down okay when that
has to be the case because if obviously
it has to work that way if one goes up
the other has to go down the
socio-economic status of a woman is
almost determines almost zero of her
attractiveness towards a man whereas the
socioeconomic status of a man is a major
determinant of his attractiveness
towards a woman and it isn't as wealth
either because that's been tested it's
his capacity to generate and be
productive and to share because that
beats the hell out of wealth wealth can
disappear right but the capacity to be
productive and share that's that's a
much more important element and why not
be chosen on the basis of that
especially because women have to have
infants and infants make the women
dependent and the woman is just looking
logically rationally and from an
evolutionary perspective for someone
who's useful enough to give a tool and a
hat so
women make intense demands on man and
it's no wonder but the thing is is that
because women engaged in hypergamy at
least in part we diverged quite rapidly
from chimpanzees because the selection
pressure that women placed on men
developed the entire species now there's
two things that happened as far as I
could tell the men competed for
competence let's say so the male
hierarchy is a mechanism that pushes the
best man to the top virtually by
definition and then that's that's the
effect of that is multiplied by the fact
that women who are a program must peel
from the top and so that the males who
are the most competent are much more
likely to leave offspring and that
seemed to be what drove our cortical
expansion for example which happened
very very rapidly over the course of
evolutionary time so and when the woman
saw that the tree was good for food and
it was pleasant to the eyes and a tree
to be desired to make one wise she took
of the fruit thereof and did eat and
gave also unto her husband with her and
he did eat
oh yes and women share food that's a
very strange thing because most
creatures don't do that right most
animals don't share food like if you if
you're a wolf and you bring down
something in a hunt you eat your fill
the dominant mate creatures eat their
fill and then if there's some left over
the subordinates get to eat too but that
isn't how human beings work we share
food now you can imagine how that
evolved because lots of female creatures
share food with their offspring okay you
don't need much of a twist in that from
an evolutionary perspective til you
start to share food not only with your
offspring se but with your mate and
that's another way that you entice a
mate it's like we're going to be better
together then alone well that's the
offering of the fruit well what's the
self conscious part well
here's part of the bargain you know I'm
going to wake you up and partly I'm
going to wake you up because you need to
be woken up because I have this infant
that needs some damn care so you bloody
well better be awake and part of the
bargain is all offer you something I'll
offer you some food and in response
we're going to make a team and that's
the deal on that's the human deal and
that's why we're more or less monogamous
by why we more or less pair bond and why
something approximating marriage is a
human Universal it's cross-cultural now
you can find exceptions but who the hell
cares
just really man who cares the Vic you
look at the vast pattern the vast
pattern well in the price we pay for
having large brains is that we're very
dependent and it takes a long time for
us to get programmed and because of that
we need relatively stable family bonding
and that's basically what we've evolved
and you know you don't get that without
making men self-conscious because male
creatures
why not impregnate and run I mean why
the hell not
and that's something to really no
kidding like that's the thing to think
about it is not why man abandoned their
children that's the mystery it's why any
men ever stick with them that's the
mystery because you just have to look at
the animal kingdom and that like the
simplest and easiest thing is always the
most likely thing to occur so it's the
exception that long-term commitment that
needs explanation she took of the fruit
thereof and did eat and gave also unto
her husband with her and he did eat and
the eyes of both of them were opened
implying that before that they were
closed and they knew they were naked and
they sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons so that's so
interesting so their eyes are open which
indicates that they weren't to begin
with so whatever God created to begin
with was kind of blind Indian but not
blind in some strange way because they
weren't obviously wandering around in
the garden bumping into trees it was
some sort of metaphysical blindness
that's been removed by whatever has just
happened and whatever's just happened
also made them realize that they were
naked okay so what sort of eye opening
is that what does it mean to realize
that you're naked it means to realize
that you're vulnerable that's what
people discovered it's like oh we can be
hurt so you're a zebra in a herd of
zebras and there's a bunch of lions
around there
laying on the grass you don't care those
are laying down Lions laying down lions
are no problem it's standing up hunting
Lions that are the problem you're not
smart enough to figure out that laying
down lines turn into standing up hunting
Lions so you're not like building a fort
to keep the Lions out you're just
mindlessly eating grass you're not very
awake but that's not what happens to
human beings is they wake up and they
think we're vulnerable permanently it's
never going away
right it's the it's the recognition of
that eternal vulnerability
what happens the first thing they do is
clothe themselves well what happens when
you're naked when you need protection
from the world well obviously look
you're all wearing clothes you know why
well we've been doing that for a very
very long period of time it's tens of
thousands of years at minimum factor you
can track more or less when clothing
developed because you can do DNA testing
of the kind of lice that cling to
clothes rather than hair and so we have
a pretty good idea of when clothing
emerged and of different types as well
so that's quite cool but the point is
they're naked and they think that's not
so good we're vulnerable so their eyes
were open enough so they become
self-conscious and they recognize their
own vulnerability and the first thing
they do is the first step of culture is
to protect themselves with something
from the world and you protect yourself
from the world and from the prying eyes
of other people this is the book by
Linnaeus Bell why we see so well from
the temptation of the eve to the
venomous murder of the Mighty Thor the
serpent appears throughout time and
culture as a figure of mischief and
mystery misery the worldwide prominence
of snakes and religion myth and folklore
underscores our deep connection to the
serpent but why when so few of us have
first-hand experience the surprising
answer this book suggests lies in the
singular effect of snakes on primate
evolution predation pressure from snakes
líneas Bell tells us is ultimately
responsible for the superior vision and
large brains of primates and for a
critical aspect of human evolution that
was tested recently psychologists have
known for a long time that people are
can learn fear to snakes but they
discovered in primates recently a set of
neurons Palvin or neural neurons which
are specialized that that's an old old
perceptual systems reveal
neurobiological evidence of past
selection for rapid detections of snakes
so that's from 2013 so the snake
definitely woke us up color vision as an
adaptation to fruit eating in primates
it's not by accident that women make
themselves look like ripe fruit in order
to be attractive to men right and that's
also not socio-cultural in origin so and
they heard the voice of the Lord God
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day and Adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the Lord
amongst the trees of the garden that's
interesting so what's the implication
prior to being woken up prior to
recognizing nakedness and vulnerability
there is no reason for God for men and
women to hide from God now are they
hiding from God while they're naked
they're vulnerable
ok so think about this think about this
it's like imagine that you have the
capacity to live truthfully and
courageously and forthrightly just
imagine that and then imagine why you
might not do that and then imagine how
about fear and shame how would that work
well let's say that the idea of living
forthrightly and truthfully and
courageously is analogous given what we
already know about these stories -
walking with God in the garden what
stops people from doing that what stops
people from hiding well it's their own
way it's a recognition of their own
inadequacy they look at themselves and I
think how in the world is a creature
since his I supposed to live properly in
this world with everything that's wrong
with me
and so what do you hide from well you
you go home you sit on your bed for five
minutes and ask yourself what have you
hidden from in your life man you'll have
books of knowledge reveal themselves to
you in your imagination right so well
why are you hiding well it's no bloody
wonder you're hiding it's no wonder that
people hide that's the thing that's so
terrifying about this story we woke up
and we thought oh my God look at this
place like this is seriously there's
some serious trouble here and we're in
some serious trouble and we're not what
we could be and so we hide and that's
what the story says people woke up they
became self-conscious they recognized
their own vulnerability and that made
them made them hide from manifesting
their divine destiny it's like yeah
that's exactly right and the Lord go
there I love this part of the story and
that's so funny and the Lord God called
and we could use a little humor at this
point and the Lord God called him to
Adam and said unto Him where art thou
and Adam said I heard thy voice in the
garden and I was afraid because I was
naked so in case there was any doubt
about that that's why and I hid myself
and God said who told you that you were
naked
did you eat of the tree where have I
commanded you that you should not eat
and this is where Adam shows himself in
all his post-fall heroic glory and the
man said the woman whom thou gave us to
be with me she gave me of the tree and I
did eat so that's that heard man that's
such that it's so you know again there's
a modern feminist interpretation of the
story of Adam and Eve that makes the
claim that Eve was portrayed as the
universal bad guy of humanity for
disobeying God and eating the Apple it's
like fair enough you know looks like she
slipped up and then she tempted her
husband and you know that makes her even
worse although he's was foolish enough
to immediately eat so it just means she
was a little more courageous than him
then got there first
but it's Adam who comes across as really
one sad creature in this story as far as
I'm concerned well c'mon he manages in
one sentence it's like first of all it
wasn't him it was the woman and since it
even blames God more than just the woman
it was that woman and you gave her to me
and she gave me of the tree and I did
eat it's like so hey Adams all innocent
except now he's not only is he naked and
disobedient and cowardly and ashamed
he's also snively backbiting
think he wraps her out like the sick and
he gets the opportunity and then he
blames God it's like and that's exactly
right
that's exactly right man you go online
and you read you read the commentary
that men write about women when they're
resentful and bitter about women you
read it it's so interesting it's like
it's not me it's those okay
that's right it's not me it's them and
not only that what a bloody world this
is in which they exist
it's exactly the same thing it's exactly
the same thing and it is absolutely
pathetic all right and the Lord God said
unto the woman what is this that thou
has done and the woman said the serpent
beguiled me and I did eat well he she
has a bloody excuse first of all it's a
snake I mean those things are we already
found out there's subtle and second it
turns out that the damn snake is Satan
himself you know and he's rather
treacherous so the fact that she got
tangled up in his mess let's say is well
problematic but it's a hell of a lot
better excuse that Adam has and the Lord
God says unto the serpent because thou
has done done this thou art cursed above
all cattle and above every beast of the
field upon thy belly shalt thou go and
dust shalt thou eat all the days of my
life and snakes by the way are lizards
that lost their legs just so you know
and I will put enmity between thee and
the woman and between thy seed and her
seed it shall bruise thy head and thou
shalt bruise his heel I love these
pictures they're so smart and again
strip the religious context from them
and just look at them for a second what
do you see you see the eternal mother
holding her infant away from the snake
see it down there right
crocodile snake everything predatory
that's been after us for like 60 million
years the reason we're here is because
of that that's why it's a sacred image
you know this one I like even better see
down there there's something like the
moon and then there's a reptile down
there that Eve is standing on this is
really old and I showed you this before
but I think it's so cool
she's coming out of this thing that's
like a hole in the sky you know because
it indicates the eternal re presence of
this figure it's something like that the
eternal recurrence of this figure it's
an archetype but then the potential out
of which she is emerging these are all
musical instruments back here
and so what the artist is representing
is the great patterns complexity of
being and the emergence of the
protective mother from that background
protecting the infant eternally against
predation it's like how can I not be a
holy image if it isn't the holy image if
you don't think it's a holy image then
there isn't something wrong with the
image there's something wrong with the
perceiver until the woman he said well
God's just outlining the consequences of
this right now it's like okay well now
you've gone and done it you've woken up
this is what's going to happen
I'll greatly multiply thy sorrow and thy
conception in sorrow thou shalt bring
forth children and thy desire shall be
to thy husband and he shall rule over
thee to say he should says he will why
in sorrow shalt thou bring forth
children well when you develop a brain
that big so that you can see it's not
that easy to give birth anymore and then
you produce something that's dependent
the own belief and that's one of the
things that you would say dooms you to
precisely this so--that's ease
punishment for waking up and Adam
because thou has hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife and his eaten of the
tree of which I commanded thee saying
thou shalt not eat it cursed is the
ground for thy sake in sorrow shalt thou
eat of it in all the days of thy life
what's that the invention of work thorns
and thistles shall it bring forth to
thee and thou shalt eat the herb of the
field
it's the invention of work what do
people do that animals don't work what
does work mean means you've sacrificed
the present for the future why do you do
that because you know you're vulnerable
because you're awake and so from here on
in from this point there's no return to
unconscious paradise I don't care how
many problems you've solved so that
today is okay you've got a lot of
problems coming up and no bloody matter
how much you work you're never going to
work enough to solve them and so all
you're going to do from here on in is be
terrified of the future and that's the
price of waking up and that's the end of
paradise and that's the beginning of
history and that's how that story goes
in the sweat of thy face shalt thou eat
bread till thou return unto the ground
for out of it was though taken for dust
thou art and unto dust thou shalt return
and Adam called his wife's name Eve
because she was the mother of all living
unto Adam also and unto his wife did the
Lord God make coats of skin and clothed
them that's William Blake by the way and
the Lord God said Behold the man has
become as one of us to know good and
evil and now lest he put forth his hand
and take also of the tree of life and
eat and live forever I'll go over this
again next week
therefore the Guillard God sent him from
the forth forth from the Garden of Eden
to till the ground from whence he was
taken so he drove out the man and he
placed at the east of the Garden of Eden
cherubims and a flaming sword which
turned every way to keep the way of the
Tree of Life
one more thing and then we'll stop so I
thought why in the world so Adam and Eve
are tempted by the snake they eat the
fruit they wake up they realize they're
naked they realize that they're
vulnerable they realize the future they
realize they're going to die they
realize that they have to work it
accounts for difficulty in conception
and the fall of humankind from
unconscious paradise okay that makes
sense
what about the knowledge of good and
evil what in the world does that mean
the Mesopotamians believed that human
beings were made out of the blood of
King knew who was the worst monster the
time out who was the goddess of chaos
could imagine and then produce so their
idea was that whatever was about
humanity there was something deeply
deeply deeply demonically flawed so
that's their conception and then some of
that same milieu that these stories
emerge so what is opening your eyes and
realizing your vulnerability have to do
with the knowledge of good and evil
really I thought about that I really
thought about that I got to tell you I
thought about that for like 20 years
because I knew there was something there
that I could not put together and at the
same time I was I was reading things I'm
going to tell you something truly awful
and so if you need a trigger warning
you're you're getting one and believe me
I do not give trigger warnings lightly
so I'm going to tell you something you
will never forget so this is what unit
731 used to do in China and China said
Japanese unit during the first second
world war right as far as I can tell
they did the most horrific things that
we're done to anyone during World War
two and that's really something so this
is what they did they took their
prisoners and they would put them in a
position so that their arms would freeze
solid and then they would take them
outside and pour hot water over their
arms and then it would repeat that till
the flesh came off the bones and they
were doing that to investigate the
treatment of frostbite for soldiers you
can look up unit 731 if you want to have
nightmares
so that's a unit 731 that's human-beings
someone thought that up and then people
did it that's knowledge of good and evil
here's the here's the key man you know
you're vulnerable no other animal knows
that you know what hurts you because
you're vulnerable now that you know what
hurts you you can figure out what hurts
someone else and as soon as you know
what hurts someone else and you can use
that you have the knowledge of good and
evil well it's a pretty good trick that
the snake code because it doesn't look
like it's exactly the sort of thing that
we might have wanted if we would have
known what the consequence was but as
soon as a human being is self conscious
and aware of his own nakedness then he
has the capacity for evil and that is
that's introduced into the world right
at that point and here's the rest of the
story so there's the snake right and
you're some tree dwelling primate and
the snake eats you and that sucks so
that's like let's watch out for the damn
snakes and then you think well wait a
minute your brain grows and think wait a
minute well there's not just snake
there's where snakes live why don't we
just get the hell out of the tree and go
hunt down the snakes and get rid of them
so those are sort of like potential
snakes and so the snake becomes
potential snake and it's the same
circuit that you're using to do this
thinking and then you get rid of the
damn snakes
it's like st. Patrick chases the mug of
Ireland no more snakes
everything's paradise it's like no no no
that's not that's not how it works no
well now you've got the human snakes
you're a tribe you've got tribal enemies
you got to defend yourself against the
human snakes right so maybe your empire
expands and you get rid of all the human
snakes and then what happens well they
start to grow developed inside it's like
you get rid of all the external enemies
and you make a big city and all of a
sudden there's enemies that pop up
inside because the snake isn't just the
snake in the garden and the snake isn't
just the possible snake and the snake
isn't just the snake that's your enemy
the snake is your friend right because
your friend can betray you and then it's
even worse than that because you can
betray you and so even if you get rid of
all the outside snakes you've got an
inside snake and god only knows what
it's up to
and that's why the bloody Christians
associated the snake in the Garden of
Eden with Satan it's unbelievably
brilliant because you got to think
what's the enemy well it's the snake
fair enough but you know that's good if
you're a tree dwelling primate but if
you're a sophisticated human being you
know with six million years of that
additional evolution and you're really
trying to solve the problem of what it
is that's the great enemy of mankind
well it's the human propensity for evil
right as such well that's the figure of
Satan that's what that figure means just
like there's a logos that's the truth
that speaks order out of chaos at the
beginning of time there's an
antithetical spirit the hostile brother
that's Cain - Abel which we'll talk to
talk about next week that's doing
exactly the opposite it's motivated by
absolutely nothing but malevolence and
the willingness to destroy and it has
every reason for doing so and that's
what's revealed in the next story in
Cain and Abel in one paragraph the first
glimmerings of that outside of the
strange insistence by the Christian
mystics let's say on the identity
between the snake in the Garden of Eden
and the author of all evil himself
[Applause]
okay so we only have 15 minutes today I
I wanted to finish that so apologies for
going over a little longer all right hi
dr. Peterson over the last couple weeks
and further back you talked a lot about
consciousness and the importance of it I
was hoping to get your opinion on an
issue of consciousness that has often
seen Christianity among other groups and
politics kind of clashed so I'm hoping
to get your views on any consciousness
or lack thereof of a human fetus and how
that impact or even bortion whatever
they are and any legislation
thank you thank you okay so the first
question is do I have an answer for that
that's a good enough answer to actually
reveal I know I don't but I can flail
about a little bit around it abortion is
clearly wrong I don't think anybody
debates that you wouldn't recommend that
someone that you love have one
okay now having clarified that that mere
statement doesn't eliminate the
complexity of the situation the first
question is is should everything wrong
be illegal that's a tough question
everything that's wrong isn't illegal
then there's the additional complication
of the difference let's say in gravity
regarding the problem in relationship to
men and women and we don't know how to
deal with that having said that I would
say that it's actually the wrong
question there's a something Leonard
Cohen said once he said that in a
massacre there's no decent place to
stand
and what he meant by that was sometimes
you're where there is no good decision
left no matter what you do it's wrong so
then the question is how did you get
there well let's say you're in a
position where you are inclined to seek
an abortion the question is how did you
get there
now we have a lot to straighten out
about the sexual relationships between
men and women in the modern world
they're bent and warped and demented out
of shape one of the things I see with
young people for example is that they
will engage in sexual acts with one
another that they would not talk about
with one another I mean couples will do
that for that matter like married
couples will do that but they're married
that's that's a different story
it seems to me that if you are willing
to engage in a sexual act with someone
with whom you would not discuss that act
you probably put the cart before the
horse so the discussion regarding the
legality of abortion is nested inside a
larger discussion about the morality of
abortion and that's disconnected inside
a larger discussion about the proper
place of sexuality and human behavior
and to me that's the level at which the
problem needs to be addressed now I
don't have the answer to that you know
because the old answer was get married
that was a good answer and it's an
answer that people should still listen
to but we'll put that aside momentarily
I had a client at one point who was I
don't know she was probably I'm not I'm
going to disguise her in a variety of
different ways she was 27 2008 come from
a relatively conservative background
quite a timid fearful person and also
not very well not sophisticated in
relationship to relationships and she
never had sex what was a bunch of things
she'd never done well the answer from me
to her wasn't continued to be timid
about everything because that wasn't
working out for her she needed to go
have some adventures
now sexual adventures like other
adventures are dangerous and so you have
to be very careful when you encourage
people to go out and have adventures but
but but too much timidity and caution
also constitutes a pathway to perdition
let's say you can't just say to people
in the modern world well you know sex
till you're married unless you're going
to get married when you're very young
and perhaps you should I don't know
about that but I don't think that we're
mature enough as a culture to have a
serious discussion about sexual
propriety especially in the aftermath of
the birth control pill and we seriously
need to do that and we have it and so I
think the eternal debate about abortion
horrible as it is is a it's the surface
manifestation of a much deeper problem
now I talked a little bit today about
the utility of marriage like the
spiritual utility of marriage and that's
something that I think we're so
immaturely cynical as a culture like we
don't we're not wise enough to look at
an institution like marriage and to
really think about what it means and
what it signifies it signifies a place
that people could tie the ropes of their
lives together so that they're stronger
it signifies a place where people can
tell the truth to one another
it signifies a place where sexuality can
properly be integrated into life that's
no easy that's an easy task it's a place
where children at least in principle can
be put first and foremost as they should
be once they exist and so there's a much
broader discussion that has to happen I
think before any concentration on the
legality of abortion is liable to get
anywhere at all that's what it looks
like to me so that's the best I can do
with that question
hi dr. Peterson earlier you showed a
picture of Foxy and Noah yeah right uh
and and Osiris and in your maps of
meaning life yeah you also explained
that cultures around the world have
these twin snakes yeah they're
everywhere man yeah and so you mentioned
that you believe this is a
representation of DNA you would bring
that up to Jesus what is it with you
guys tonight huh yeah well yeah no I
wouldn't say I believe that I have my
suspicions that that might be it yeah
because believe is too strong a word but
those representations are everywhere and
read this book this is a good one oh man
now I have to remember the book by an
anthropologist who went down to the
Amazon jungle and experimented
intensively with ayahuasca I think it's
called the cosmic serpent I think that's
the name of the book you could read that
there's another one called breaking open
the head which is also pretty damn
interesting and there's something to
those books
I mean the cosmic serpent kind of goes
off on a bit of a tangent I would say
although breaking open the head is it's
better better it seems to stay more
constrained and tight but there's we
don't know the limits of our perception
especially under certain conditions and
I think people have had intimations of
DNA as the cosmic serpent forever so
yeah but that's a like that's way out on
the frontiers of my knowledge right like
I'm guessing in a dreamlike way when I'm
making statements like that so because
he didn't mention that you did believe
in and that there were sort of maybe
some some dreams and interpretations
that might have emerged but I don't see
how we could perceive DNA as it is right
well yes we did we didn't objectively
but I'm not so sure we didn't
subjectively
but it means very strange that these did
these double helixes exist in so many
places and that they're often utilized
as healing symbols with the snake so
anyways like I said that's what do you
call that
I'm it's not hypothesizing it's one
thing worse than that speculating those
are speculations I'm I'm operating at
the edge of my understanding but our
perceptions can are very mutable and
they can we can see things under some
conditions that you wouldn't think that
anybody could see so okay yep
so I was just starting to have a thought
while you're talking about sort of
getting to the end of the talk about the
snake and the Apple and so on so what
you're saying is the moment that that
that Adam and Eve eat the Apple they
become nervous or whatever so that's
awareness of their own vulnerability so
then like you said it's also awareness
of their own capacity to do harm so it's
like when they are eating the Apple then
that's them their immediate sort of
nervous reaction is is because they ate
the Apple and they kind of became evil
in that moment or something like that
well they woke up and because they they
woke up and realized how they could be
hurt how they could and would be hurt
over the over the over the upcoming
overtime it's the same as the discovery
of the discovery of your own nakedness
and the discovery of time are very very
similar phenomena
I mean sure as soon as you know how you
can be hurt well you know if you are to
just consult your evil fantasies it's
like what'll really hurt him oh yeah
that would work it's like how do you
know that well you just think about it
what would happen if that happened to me
that would hurt oh yeah that'll work
it'll hurt him or her and you know you
probably think that way twice a week or
maybe twice a day Jesus every time you
have an argument with someone all you
have to do is look at the back of your
mind a little bit you don't want to
that's for sure but if you do you'll see
these sorts of thought process is
generating constantly it's like you know
in a back-and-forth discussion
particularly with people you love it's
like you're always looking for a place
to put the knife in so
it seems really similar to me or seems
like they're kind of discovering the
kind of like Union shadow within
themselves so that that is the moment
where it got introduced into the human
spirit sure one of the things about the
shadow is that it's also when you
integrate that that's what makes you a
substantial person right oh it's like it
seems to me that on one hand well it
seems like this tragedy that's Satan the
most evil the father of evil whatever
has introduced into people but it also
seems like without that shadow that
people are kind of insubstantial
so yeah well right right I mean like I
said I said that there's been a
multitude of interpretations emerge as a
consequence of that story what was God
up to what was God in fact evil the
initial God like why would he create a
snake why would he put it in the garden
why would there be these trees what the
hell is going on with the whole Satan
thing you know it's very very
problematic well we'll talk about it
more and then this again is let's call
it speculation well if you want to make
something strong you test it and maybe
if you want to make something ultimately
strong you test it ultimately and I
think that there's an aspect of being
that has that element is that human
beings are tempted ultimately it's
partly because we know good and good and
evil now and so that's the landscape in
which we exist so you could say the
landscape is across its chaos and order
and it's good and evil and we're stuck
in the middle between those two things
it's a very common theme by the way in
videogames exactly that chaos order good
evil it's the it's the basic plot of
endless video games and that's perhaps
because it's the basic plot those are
the things we have to contend with well
I had a vision once shouldn't tell you
this but I will anyways I had a vision
once that I went to heaven and I was put
in a in a Roman amphitheater with Satan
just like Thor encountering the Hulk
right that's coming up in that New
Avengers movie
so it was rather a shock because I
thought there was a hell of a thing to
happen in heaven and so I had this
battle and I won and at the end I came
up to God and said like you know what's
with the whole Roman amphitheater thing
there it seemed like it over the top to
me said why would you put me in a ring
with some one thing like that and he
said because I knew you could win and
you know I don't know what to make of
that
haha one thing I should teach you to
make of it as I shouldn't tell you but
whatever but you know there's something
there's something to that in my
estimation it's like do you protect the
people you love or do you try to make
them strong so you think it's that it's
not that we have like Satan to thank for
making us substantial it's that God gave
us Satan in order to make us substantial
well I'd hesitate to say that because
you know it's so cut and dried but I
would say that that there's this that's
a strong underlying theme in the
biblical narrative yes now it's
certainly not the only theme it's not
the only interpretation by any stretch
of the imagination but there is
something there and there's something
there you know at the end we didn't talk
about this God puts up his flaming sword
and these cherubim to keep you away from
the tree of life it's like it's see if
paradise and immortality are the
promised land and what's with the whole
flaming angel and sword thing we could
have just had the damn fruit five
thousand years ago and not bothered with
the problem well it seems to me that
there's something like I don't know what
it is consciousness through tragedy
clarity through suffering maybe
something like that or maybe the
perfection that lurks as a potential in
the future is something that has to be
earned rather than given maybe it has no
value without free choice maybe we have
to distinguish between good and evil now
that we have the capacity to actually
apprehend them maybe that's what life is
about
maybe that's the separating of the wheat
from the chaff see that's the idea in
Revelation right because when Christ
comes back in the book of Revelation he
divides the Damned from the saved
and the saved are the people who lived
in logos roughly speaking and the Damned
or those who don't and so there's this
idea that there's this dynamic that
underlies experience that is in fact
that sorting now I don't know what to
make of that
at all but that's the story but what I
can make of that is that I I can't put a
lever underneath the argument that I
just made tonight about the relationship
between the development of vision the
snake of fruit
nakedness time the future work and most
importantly the emergence of evil that
seems to me to be I cannot find a way to
undermine that argument it seems I can't
break it and that's what I'm always
looking for when I'm trying to formulate
ideas I'm trying to look for something
that no matter how hard I try I cannot
break and I can't break that set of
ideas now what the full implication is
of that set of ideas god only knows
right but but I could say also
practically you know one of the things
that I've observed is that lies and
deception destroy people's lives and
when they start telling the truth and
acting it out things get a lot better
gotta stop
[Applause]